I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everybody. Hi there.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了这部终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能讲述的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女郎，大家好。大家好。
Today, we are breaking down season seven, episode 16, PDA, and we have a special guest in the studio with us. We do. The director of this episode, Greg Daniels. Hi, Greg. Hi, guys. Welcome. Thank you for having me.
今天，我们要剖析第七季第16集《办公室恋情》（PDA），我们在录音室里有一位特别嘉宾。没错。本集的导演，格雷格·丹尼尔斯。嗨，格雷格。大家好。欢迎。谢谢邀请我来。
I have been in editing lately and I'm going back as soon as we're done. I am still editing with Dave Rogers. You are? Yes. So we're on a link, a Zoom link. It's not in person anymore. Is it harder to edit over Zoom? Yes, because the thing keeps lagging.
我最近一直在剪辑，一结束我马上就要回去了。我还在和戴夫·罗杰斯一起剪辑。是吗？是的。所以我们是通过链接，一个Zoom链接。已经不是面对面了。通过Zoom剪辑更难吗？是的，因为那玩意儿总是卡顿。
Oh, no. We still haven't worked out all the technical parts. What are you guys editing right now? We are editing the first episode of season three of Upload, which we just finished shooting. That is awesome. I went to the Upload premiere and Jenna, I looked at the red carpet and they were like, do you want to do red carpet? And I was like, oh, no, no.
哦，不。我们还没把所有技术问题都解决好。你们现在在剪辑什么？我们在剪辑《上载新生》第三季的第一集，我们刚刚拍完。太棒了。我去参加了《上载新生》的首映礼，珍娜，我看着红毯，他们问，你想走红毯吗？我说，哦，不，不。
I'm just here to support Greg. And I step back, the most beautiful people who walked by onto that red carpet. Your cast is so beautiful. I took a photo with Robbie Amell and Amy Allo and Allegra Edwards and Zaynep. And they all kind of got into that model pose where they put one foot forward and like cocked their hips. And I was like, what the hell am I doing on this stage with these people? I thought you looked very handsome that night.
我只是来支持格雷格的。当我退后时，那些最美的人走上了红毯。你们的演员阵容太美了。我和罗比·阿梅尔、艾美·阿罗、阿莱格拉·爱德华兹以及泽伊内普拍了张照片。他们都摆出了那种模特姿势，一只脚向前迈，胯部微侧。当时我就想，我到底在跟这些人一起在这个舞台上干什么？我觉得那天你看起来非常帅气。
And we have a great photo. I took with Greg. I put myself on the side so that it would be easy for them to edit me out for the publicity photos. But anyway, this episode that we're about to talk about was edited by Dave and Claire Scanlon whose birthday it is today. Oh, happy birthday, Claire. Yeah.
我们有一张很棒的照片。我和格雷格拍的。我把自己站在边上，这样他们为宣传照把我P掉就会很容易了。不管怎样，我们接下来要谈的这一集是由戴夫和克莱尔·斯坎伦剪辑的，今天是她的生日。哦，克莱尔，生日快乐。是的。
Greg, you know, there is a commentary for this episode and you and I are both on it. Oh, I forgot about that. You say some interesting things. I'm really curious because you guys told me about this and I literally forgot that I directed it or had anything to do with it. And I was, I was looking, I was like, God, I don't have any anecdotes. I don't even remember doing this. And I went back and watched it again and it's a really fun episode.
格雷格，你知道，这一集有导演评论音轨，你和我都在上面。哦，我都忘了。你说了些有趣的话。我真的很好奇，因为你们跟我说过这个，但我literally（简直）忘了我导演过它，或者跟它有任何关系。我当时在看，心想，天哪，我没有任何趣闻。我甚至不记得拍过这个。我又回去看了一遍，这真是一集很有趣的剧。
You should be very proud of your work. I am. I am actually as a craftsman, as like a directorial craftsman, I'm like, oh, that was a good shot. Oh, look at that reveal. Oh, there's some good things here. There's sort of good moves. I thought one of the things I was a big fan of, and I know we're sort of jumping all over the place, but in the conference room, when Gabe is like, look, you guys can't act like
你应该为你的作品感到非常骄傲。我是。作为一个手艺人，作为一个导演手艺人，我确实觉得，哦，那个镜头真好。哦，看那个惊艳亮相。哦，这里有些不错的镜头。有些挺好的运镜。我觉得我非常喜欢的一个地方——我知道我们有点东拉西扯——但在会议室里，当盖比说，听着，你们不能这样……
this, right? In the office and they're having this meeting about it. It's a really long scene, but you have them first sitting facing Gabe and then once they realize it's about them, you turn them around in the chair and now they're facing all of us. It was so hard to get through that without laughing. That was so tough. That was very funny.
对吧？在办公室里，他们正在开关于这个的会。这是一个非常长的场景，但你先让他们面向盖比坐着，然后一旦他们意识到这是针对他们的，你就让他们把椅子转过来，现在他们面对着我们所有人。要在不笑场的情况下拍完这一幕太难了。太难了。非常搞笑。
I think to me, some of the best part was there was a lot of b-roll in this episode and it was b-roll of like, Jim and Pam trying to find some place to mess around in. The one where you guys are going up the ladder and the... Into the warehouse. In the warehouse. Yeah. And then it just, the camera just reveals Calvin and you guys zoomed down. That was pretty funny.
对我来说，我觉得最精彩的一部分是这一集里有很多B卷镜头（b-roll），都是吉姆和帕姆试图找个地方亲热的B卷镜头。你们爬梯子那个，还有……去仓库。在仓库里。是的。然后镜头一转，拍到了卡尔文，你们俩滑了下去。挺搞笑的。
I feel like I remember there's a shot of John and he's going to suggest maybe we get into a box. There is. Yeah. For some reason, I feel like we saw that box and that was an idea on the day. I thought that was really funny. I went back and looked at the script, which I sent to my phone in case we would reference it.
我好像记得有一个约翰的镜头，他建议说也许我们可以钻进一个箱子里。有的。是的。不知为什么，我觉得我们看到了那个箱子，那是当场想到的一个主意。我觉得挺搞笑的。我回去看了剧本，我把它发到了手机上，以防我们需要参考它。
But now the thought of digging it out and finding it on my phone, on my tiny little phone, is impossible. But I was looking for certain things because I felt like, oh yeah, was that actually scripted? And there was a good bit of improv, like the thing about the monkeys throwing their poop was all, of course, improv. Yes. Yeah. Yeah.
但现在一想到要把剧本挖出来，在我的手机上——我的那个小手机上找它，简直是不可能完成的任务。但我当时在找某些东西，因为我觉得，哦，是的，那真的是剧本里写的吗？里面有不少即兴发挥，比如猴子扔便便的那段，当然全部都是即兴发挥。是的。是的。是的。
That scene ended much sooner. Yeah. Yeah. Well, would we want a summary for this episode? I always like a summary. Thank you, Angela. All right. Since you write them, I want to hear it.
那个场景结束得早得多。是的。是的。好吧，我们想要这一集的剧情摘要吗？我一向喜欢摘要。谢谢你，安吉拉。好吧。既然是你写的，我想听听。
All right. This was written by Robert Padnick. Yes. Yes. Yes. Who has gone on to write on so many other shows. Great news. Mm-hmm.
好吧。这一集是罗伯特·帕德尼克写的。是的。是的。是的。他后来为非常多的其他节目编写了剧本。好消息。嗯哼。
Chad. Man seeking woman. Are you still in touch with Robert? I am. I went on a walk with him about a month ago in the middle of the night. So. There's a night walk. What's the story?
查德。《男神求爱记》。你还和罗伯特保持联系吗？是的。大约一个月前我和他在半夜去散步了。所以。还有夜间散步。怎么回事？
Do you often night walk? Yes. I am a night walker. I will basically, when I'm in editing, which I've been in for a while, I will look at my phone at the end of the day and I will realize that I took 230 steps that day. I can relate to that. Since I'm editing in my own house over Zoom. And then when that happens, I kind of go nuts and I go out on these long rambly walks
你经常夜间散步吗？是的。我是个夜行者。基本上，当我在做剪辑时——我已经做了一段时间了——我会在一天结束时看手机，然后发现我那天走了230步。我对此感同身受。因为我在自己家里通过Zoom剪辑。然后当这种情况发生时，我就会有点抓狂，然后我会去进行这些漫长、漫无目的的散步……
in the dark. Do you like have a headlamp or some kind of lighted fixture on you? I have a thing that I got sort of from King of the Hill days called a Bubba Stick, which is a walking stick with a big brass knob on the end of it. Okay. So. What does that do? Does that light your way?
在黑暗中。你戴着头灯或者某种照明设备吗？我有个东西，是从《山丘之王》那个时期弄来的，叫巴巴棍（Bubba Stick），是一根顶端带着一个大黄铜圆头的步行杖。好吧。那有什么用？那是用来照路的吗？
Or is it just a weapon? There's no light. It's just for cobwebs and you and I'm going through things and to intimidate people who might come your way. I don't like the office who may be lurking. I like to night walk too. I have a path I do, but I did buy myself a headlamp, but I don't wear it on my head. I just kind of tie it to my wrist.
还是只是一把武器？没有光。它只是用来对付蜘蛛网的，还有……如果你要穿过一些地方，以及用来威吓那些可能靠近你的人。我不喜欢办公室里那些可能潜伏的人。我也喜欢夜间散步。我有我常走的一条路，但我确实给自己买了一个头灯，不过我不把它戴在头上。我只是把它系在手腕上。
It's just really a good look. So I'm out there in the neighborhood like that. I'll keep an eye out for you. I'll keep an eye out for you and your big stick. That doesn't sound right. But you know, you know what I mean? Nevermind. Okay.
这造型真的很不错。所以我就是那样在社区里转悠的。我会帮你留意的。我会留意你和你那根大棍子。听起来怪怪的。不过你知道，你知道我的意思吧？没关系。好吧。
Summary. That's what she said. I hope that stays in. Yeah. All right. Here's your summary. Now that they are back together, Michael and Holly's public displays of affection are getting to be a bit too much for their coworkers.
摘要。这就是她说的。我希望这句话能保留下来。好吧。这是你的摘要。既然他们重新在一起了，迈克尔和霍莉在公共场合过于亲密的举动让同事们有点吃撑了。
Meanwhile, Andy helps Erin with her Valentine's Day treasure hunt from Gabe and Pam and Jim after getting drunk at lunch are looking for a place to get it on at the office. Bottomless mimosas. It's always a slippery slope. They never found that bottom. Fast fact number one, I'm calling it season seven overview with Greg Daniels. No pressure, Greg. Yeah.
与此同时，安迪帮艾琳寻找盖比为她准备的情人节寻宝游戏线索；而帕姆和吉姆在午餐时喝醉后，正在办公室里寻找亲热的地方。无限畅饮含羞草鸡尾酒。这总是一个滑坡。他们永远找不到底线。第一条幕后快讯，我称之为“与格雷格·丹尼尔斯一起回顾第七季”。没有压力，格雷格。是的。
It's all you. Since you're here, we really wanted to ask you a little bit about the approach to season seven, knowing that it would be Steve Krull's last year as Michael Scott. Yeah. Well, Paul Lieberstein ran this year, season seven, and I was a little bit of a broken man for season seven, I think because season six, I was also, I was co-running it with Paul and also co-running Parks and Rec, and that was my season of 58 episodes or whatever. Wow.
全靠你了。既然你来了，我们真的很想问问你关于第七季的创作思路，当时我们知道这将是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔作为迈克尔·斯科特的最后一年。是的。嗯，保罗·李伯斯坦负责了这一年，也就是第七季，而我在第七季时觉得自己有点像个破碎的人，我想是因为在第六季时，我也在和保罗联合运作（这部剧），同时还要联合运作《公园与游憩》，那是我制作了58集左右的一季。哇。
Yeah. Yeah. And so I was like a little busted up at the end of that season. So what the main thing that I remember is a lot of discussions about how do you round the psychological arc for Michael? Like he's learning little things each episode sometimes or backsliding, and he has massive psychological issues that he's been working out. And I think we wanted to give him sort of a happy ending, which meant fixing a lot of
是的。是的。所以在那一季结束时我有点垮了。所以我记得最主要的事情就是有很多关于如何为迈克尔完成心理弧光的讨论？比如他在每一集里都会学到一点小东西，有时会有所倒退，而且他身上有一直在努力解决的巨大心理问题。我想我们希望给他一个某种意义上的结局，这意味着解决他的很多问题，并时刻关注还有哪些问题需要解决。
his things and just keeping track of what remained to be addressed. And then another big challenge this year was Jim and Pam, I think, because we really wanted to make sure that we didn't put in any cheap soap opera moves for them, but they had also hit a lot of the big milestones of gotten together and gotten married and had a kid. And so one of the things I loved about this episode was they have a really good comedy story that is not pushing anything in their relationship. It's just like they're both on the same page and, you know, they're pursuing this very funny story.
然后这一年的另一个巨大挑战是吉姆和帕姆，我想是因为我们真的很想确保不为他们加入任何廉价的肥皂剧桥段，但他们也达到了许多重要的里程碑——走到了一起、结了婚并有了一个孩子。所以我喜欢这一集的原因之一是，他们有一个非常棒的喜剧故事，并没有强行推动他们关系的任何进展，只是他们俩都在同一频段上，你知道，他们正在推进这个非常有趣的剧情。
Yeah. You know, I really liked this episode because John was back. You know, John had been gone for about a month. He was shooting the movie Big Miracle with Ken Quapas up in Alaska, and he only had these like little moments in each episode because he was gone a lot. And as Pam, it was really hard not to have Jim. You know, I had some fun storylines with the resolutions and things, but I didn't realize how hungry I was for a Jim Pam storyline.
是的。你知道，我真的很喜欢这一集，因为约翰回来了。你知道，约翰已经离开大约一个月了。他当时在阿拉斯加和肯·夸帕斯一起拍电影《奇迹般的大救援》，他在每一集里只有这些小片段，因为他经常不在。作为帕姆，没有吉姆的日子真的很难熬。你知道，我和决议（委员会）之类的人有一些有趣的剧情线，但我没有意识到我是多么渴望看到吉姆和帕姆的剧情线。
I loved seeing them together. I loved their drunken stumble out of the cab. I loved them being confronted by Ryan in front of Ryan's office. I really liked having us together. If you weren't the host of this, I would gush probably 10 times more about you in this episode. But I think, first of all, I have to do a little gushing. I can leave it if you need. She's leaning back with her cup of coffee.
我喜欢看他们在一起。我喜欢他们醉醺醺地踉跄着下出租车。我喜欢他们在瑞恩的办公室前被瑞恩质问。我真的很喜欢我们能在一起。如果你不是这个节目的主持人，我可能会对你在这一集里的表现赞不绝口十倍。但我认为，首先，我得稍微赞美一下。如果你需要的话我可以走开。她靠在椅子上喝着咖啡。
She's ready. I'm here for it. Bring it on, Greg. I mean, first, I think it's very hard to act drunk, first of all. You guys did that really well. But it's also just such an endearing episode for Pam, I think, especially at the end. But there's just like, it's, I love the part where you were at the vending machine and you were like, and nobody knows except me and him, and that was like a cool way to say
她准备好了。我随时奉陪。说吧，格雷格。我是说，首先，我觉得要演出醉酒的状态非常难。你们俩演得真的很好。但这也绝对是帕姆一个非常讨人喜欢的剧集，我想，特别是在结尾。但就是那种，我最喜欢你在自动售货机旁说的那部分，你说，除了我和他没人知道，那真是一种很酷的说法。
it. Yeah. And it's just kind of, I don't know, it was exciting to see Pam be interested in the way you played drunk. The big, I'm sure we talked about it at the time, I don't know who initially said it. It's like this truism about playing drunk is that you're supposed to be fighting it the whole time. Yes.
是的。而且这有点，我不知道，看到帕姆对你演醉酒的方式感兴趣，让人很兴奋。关于演醉酒有一个很大的——我们当时肯定讨论过，我不知道最初是谁说的——一个关于演醉酒的真理，那就是你必须全程都在与之抗拒。是的。
You're not playing drunk or attempting to not play drunk. And I thought, actually, this episode turned out to be really interesting because the main plot is somewhat similar to that in that it's all about like they're not supposed to be touching each other and showing affection. And yet this amazing thing has happened that they both say that they love each other. I'm talking about Michael and Holly. And yet they're not allowed to touch each other. It's like that little limitation that they have to sort of work around.
你不是在演醉酒，而是在试图不让自己显得醉酒。我想，实际上，这一集结果非常有趣，因为主线剧情在某种程度上与此类似，都是关于他们不应该互相接触和表现出爱意。然而发生了一件了不起的事情，他们俩都说他们爱对方。我说的是迈克尔和霍莉。然而他们不被允许碰触彼此。就像那种他们必须绕过的微小限制。
I thought was really a good game to play. Well, Greg, that leads me very well into my fast fact number two, which is that this was our Valentine's Day episode. It aired on February 10th, 2011. Angela, you had a tidbit. Yes, Greg. So when I watched the commentary, you guys talked about this big debate about whether Michael and Holly should say, I love you this early into the courtship that we're seeing
我觉得这真是一个很好玩的设定。好吧，格雷格，这非常自然地引导到了我的第二条幕后快讯，那就是这是我们的情人节特辑。它于2011年2月10日播出。安吉拉，你有一个花絮。是的，格雷格。所以当我观看评论音轨时，你们讨论了一个激烈的辩论，关于迈克尔和霍莉是否应该在这个季度我们看到的恋爱初期就说“我爱你”。
this season. Like what would that do? And then you said you saw the performances by Steve and Amy and you're like, of course they have to say I love you. Were you worried about that? How serious was that conversation? Well, so interesting that you prepared by listening to the commentary, which I should have done because I have no memory of that or saying that.
这会带来什么影响？然后你说你看到了史蒂夫和艾美（丽安）的表演，心想：他们当然得说“我爱你”。你当时担心这个吗？那次谈话有多严肃？哦，真有趣，你竟然听了评论音轨来做准备，我本来也应该听的，因为我对那段记忆或说过的话全无印象。
I think the performances were great in this. And there's a number of moments where I thought, oh, well, this is the whole point. And I feel like the episode is very Paul Lieberstein to me in a way because he's a very subtle writer and important things happen, but on the surface they're small things. And he found, and obviously with Padneck, but he found this way for it to be buried in a comedy story for them to say that and to say, do you love me, love me? I love you, love you. And to me, it feels really Paul in my head.
我觉得这里的表演太棒了。有很多时刻我在想，哦，这才是重点。我觉得这一集对我来说非常具有保罗·李伯斯坦的风格，因为他是一个非常微妙的编剧，重要的事情会发生，但在表面上它们都是小事。他和帕德尼克一起——显然还有帕德尼克——但他找到了一种方式，让它们隐藏在一个喜剧故事里，让他们说出那句话，说：你爱我——爱我吗？我爱——爱你的。对我来说，在我的脑海里，这感觉真的很像保罗的风格。
And yeah, and Amy's amazing, Amy Ryan, the way she's flushed and everything. And there's like a really big romantic story point in the middle of this episode that seems like it's just about PDAs and everything, but it is a big advancement for them. But it's also episode 16 of season seven and Steve leaves like episode 20. So it's like, you gotta roll it along. Yeah. And as you guys worry, it sounded like that if, well, if they say this here, what does that mean for the next few episodes?
而且，是的，艾美的表现太惊艳了，艾米·莱恩，她脸红的样子以及一切。在这个剧集的中间有一个非常重大的浪漫剧情点，看起来好像只关于办公室恋情（PDA）之类的事情，但这对他们来说是一个巨大的进展。但这也是第七季的第16集，而史蒂夫在第20集左右就离开剧组了。所以你必须得推动情节发展。是的。正如你们担心的那样，听起来好像，如果他们在这里说了这话，那对接下来的几集意味着什么？
But it made me cry. I teared up at that scene. I thought it was so beautiful. Well I have a fun little personal tidbit about this episode. So shortly before this episode aired, I found out I was pregnant in real life. So I was not pregnant when we were shooting it, but between shooting it and it airing, I found out that I was pregnant with my first child. And what's really crazy about that is because later, when I came into your office as Greg
但这把我弄哭了。那个场景让我热泪盈眶。我觉得太美了。好吧，关于这一集我有一个有趣的小个人花絮。就在这一集播出前不久，我在现实生活中发现自己怀孕了。所以我们在拍的时候我并没有怀孕，但在拍摄和播出之间，我发现我怀上了我的第一个孩子。而这真正疯狂的地方在于，因为后来，当我作为格雷格来到你的办公室，我告诉你和保罗我怀孕了，你在想是否应该把它写进剧集里，我不记得是你还是保罗了，但你说：太完美了。吉姆和帕姆就是在邓德·米夫林怀孕的。他们是在那个杂物间里孕育了菲利普。
and I told you and Paul that I was pregnant and you were wondering if you should write it into the show, I can't remember if it was you or Paul, but you said, it's perfect. Jim and Pam got pregnant at Dunder Mifflin. They conceived Phillip in that closet. So it really points to, like, if you back up the dates, not only did Pam and Jim get it on, but this is the episode they conceived Phillip. Wow. But you did not conceive during the week of shooting.
所以这确实指向，如果你把日期往前推，不仅帕姆和吉姆亲热了，而且这就是他们孕育菲利普的那一集。哇。但你并不是在拍摄的那周受孕的。
You were already pregnant. Oh my gosh. I know where I conceived. Oh no. I'll keep that to myself. Oh my gosh. But it was over the Christmas hiatus. Yeah, that makes more sense.
你当时已经怀孕了。哦，天哪。我知道我在哪儿受孕的。哦，不。我得把这个秘密留给自己。哦，天哪。但那是在圣诞节假期期间。是的，那说得通。
So we were not shooting. No, but there must have been something was happening, right? Yeah. Well, we were, because we shot this when we got back from breaks. Well, now I want to watch it again and just picture the idea that your baby is directing some of your performances somehow. Perhaps. Ormonally.
所以我们当时没有在拍戏。不，但肯定有什么事情发生了，对吧？是的。好吧，我们在——因为我们是放假回来后拍这一集的。好吧，现在我想再看一遍，脑子里就浮现出这样一个画面：你的宝宝在某种程度上指导了你的一些表演。也许吧。通过荷尔蒙。
Maybe so. All right, fast fact number three. There were three romantic storylines in this episode. We've mentioned Michael and Holly. We've talked about Jim and Pam. There was also Andy and Aaron, but Angela might have uncovered one more. I did, but if you read the shooting draft, Greg, you probably saw it too. I had to know about the scene.
也许是这样。好吧，第三条幕后快讯。这一集里有三个浪漫的剧情线。我们提到了迈克尔和霍莉。我们谈到了吉姆和帕姆。还有安迪和艾琳，但安吉拉可能还挖出了另一个。我确实挖出来了，但如果你读过拍摄剧本，格雷格，你可能也看到了。我必须了解那个场景。
I printed it out for us in size 18 font because that's my eyesight now. Okay. This is how it read. At the end of the meeting where Gabe is discussing PDA with everyone, it read like this in the script. All eyes turned to Michael and Holly who are still hugging and haven't gotten the hint. She is tweaking his nipples. His face is frozen in stupid ecstasy.
我把它打印出来，用18号字体，因为这就是我现在的视力。好吧。剧本是这样写的。在盖比和大家讨论办公室恋情（PDA）的会议结束时，剧本里是这样写的。所有人的目光都转向迈克尔和霍莉，他们还在拥抱，根本没领会暗示。她在捏他的乳头。他的脸上凝固着愚蠢的狂喜。
Oscar says to Michael and Holly, maybe you guys should be listening. Michael says, wait, is this about Holly and me? Meredith says, no, it's about the wild sex between me and Kevin. And then she and Kevin laugh and they high five, but then they catch each other's glance just a second too long. Maybe we should. That could have been the start of something beautiful. I mean, I was like, wait, did you guys want Kevin and Meredith to hook up?
奥斯卡对迈克尔和霍莉说，也许你们俩该听听。迈克尔说，等等，这是在说我和霍莉吗？梅雷迪思说，不，这是在说我和凯文之间的狂野性爱。然后她和凯文大笑击掌，但接着他们互相注视的时间稍微久了那么一秒钟。也许我们应该……那可能是某些美好事物的开始。我是说，当时我在想，等等，你们想让凯文和梅雷迪思搞在一起吗？
Was that like a runner? I don't know. I love Kevin. She goes to another school. Oh, that was so good. And I think that probably that was so good that that dampened every other possibility for him in this episode. Yeah.
那是一个常态笑话吗？我不知道。我爱凯文。她去另一所学校了。哦，太棒了。我想这可能太棒了，以至于压倒了这一集中他所有其他的可能性。是的。
I had said to Kate, I was like, Kate, were they trying to hook Meredith up with people? She goes, there was always a joke like that, like almost every script, there was a joke about Meredith. Well, one thing's for sure, they're going to need all three of those closets because there is a lot of hooking up going on at Dunder Mifflin. Not just in the office either, in the warehouse too. I mean, we all know about Dwight and Angela. I think definitely Daryl was active in the warehouse.
我曾对凯特说，凯特，他们是想把梅雷迪思和别人凑成一对吗？她说，总是有这样的笑话，几乎每一集剧本里都有一个关于梅雷迪思的笑话。好吧，有一件事是肯定的，他们需要那三个杂物间，因为邓德·米夫林里正在发生太多的亲热事件了。不仅在办公室里，仓库里也是。我是说，我们都知道德怀特和安吉拉的事。我觉得达里尔在仓库里绝对也很活跃。
See? I like the phrase active in the warehouse. Jeff, that went down. Greg, did you have a favorite scene from this episode? When you were rewatching, was there anything that you were particularly excited about or that you remember shooting? Like I was saying about the B-roll, I loved a lot of the B-roll. I liked Michael just sitting there eating Cheetos and stuff like that, and some of that
看？我喜欢“在仓库里很活跃”这个词。杰夫，那段真精彩。格雷格，你在这集里有最喜欢的场景吗？当你重温时，有没有什么地方是你特别兴奋的，或者你还记得当时拍摄的场景？就像我刚才说的B卷镜头，我非常喜欢那些B卷镜头。我喜欢迈克尔就坐在那里吃奇多之类的东西，我觉得其中有些是我们实际拍摄时即兴发现的，这很有趣。
I feel like we discovered during the actual shooting, which was fun. But there was some, I mean, I love the ending of the Jim and Pam story. I think that, you know, there's so much about this episode where it wasn't verbal. It was like visual or behavioral, and that's always really fun for me, I think. And just that moment of the I love you, love you was probably the highlight because, you know, Michael went out on a limb and he always messes up when he goes out on a limb and says that he loves someone. He's always too early, too soon, and you're just like, oh, he's blowing it.
但也有一些——我是说，我喜欢吉姆和帕姆故事的结局。我觉得，这一集里有很多地方不是靠台词表达的。而是视觉上的或是行为上的，这对我来说总是很有趣。而且“我爱——爱你的”那个时刻可能就是高潮，因为，你知道迈克尔冒险去表白了，而他每次冒险去说爱某个人时总是会搞砸。他总是太早、太快，然后你就会想，哦，他搞砸了。
He's blowing it. And then he didn't blow it because she felt the same way. That was such a good moment. I loved it. And I loved the reaction shots while the scene was happening because Jim has this look. Like, it's very amazing that John did it because it read drunk, but also like, oh my God. But then Pam has this look that reads drunk, Jenna, but it's like, oh, no, no, Mayday, Mayday.
他要搞砸了。然后他没有搞砸，因为她有同感。那是多么美好的一个时刻。我太喜欢了。我喜欢那个场景发生时的那些反应镜头，因为吉姆有那种表情。就像，约翰演得太棒了，因为既显得喝醉了，又有一种“哦，天哪”的感觉。但帕姆有那种看起来醉醺醺的表情，珍娜，但又像是在说，不，不，梅黛，梅黛（Mayday）。
Like, no, Michael. And it just helped it build, and then she was right there where he was, and it was so perfect. Yeah. Well, when you were talking about the debate of having Michael say, I love you and is it too soon? I almost feel like it needed to be too soon because we needed the partner who was going to meet him where he is, which is a person who says it too soon.
就像，不，迈克尔。这起到了推波助澜的作用，然后她就来到了他身边，太完美了。是的。好吧，当你在谈论关于让迈克尔说“我爱你”是否太早的辩论时，我几乎觉得它就需要是太早的，因为我们需要那个能够在他所在的地方迎接他的人，而他就是一个会说得太早的人。
Even though, come on, he's earned it. He has loved Holly for a year now. And they should have said, I love you the last time they were dating. We all know they're perfect for each other. And so in that sense, also, it's not too soon. She needed that nudge, I think. The second scene that just warmed my heart was when she tells him they're over back in human resources by her desk, and she's like, work doesn't get to decide who we are to each
尽管，拜托，他已经赢得了这个资格。他爱霍莉已经有一年了。他们上一次约会时就应该说“我爱你”了。我们都知道他们是天生一对。所以从这个意义上说，其实也并不算太早。我想她需要那个推力。让我感到心里暖洋洋的第二个场景是，当她在人力资源部她的办公桌旁告诉他他们结束了，她说：工作无权决定我们对彼此而言是什么。
other. Yeah. We get to decide that. Yeah, that's a great scene. That's really well written. Great. And the look, like, that comes over Michael's face of like, OK. And even just the way Steve did it, I was like, oh, my God, my heart.
是的。我们自己决定。是的，那是个好场景。写得真好。太棒了。而且迈克尔脸上掠过的那个表情，就好像：好吧。甚至只是史蒂夫的演绎方式，我就想：哦，天哪，我的心。
Do you remember who said, I love you first and your couples? Oh, I'm always, I always say things first, guys. You're a first? I'm a Michael. I mean, yeah, the minute I feel it, I'm going to tell you, I can't hold it in. I'm still saving it. I think there's nothing better on the 50th anniversary than that first I love you. Yeah, just to confirm it.
你还记得在你们的伴侣中是谁先说“我爱你”的吗？哦，我总是——我总是先说的那个人，伙计们。你是第一个说的？我是迈克尔。我是说，是的，我一有这种感觉，我就会告诉你，我憋不住。我还留着呢。我觉得周年纪念日没有什么比那个最初的“我爱你”更好的了。是的，只是为了确认一下。
You earned it. You earned it. Here it is. It was Lee, Lee said, I love you first and he blurted it out on accident. But I was, I came right in and I was like, no, but I love you. Oh, nice. So you're just like the show. A little bit.
你赢得了这个。你赢得了这个。就是这样。是李，李先说了“我爱你”，他不小心脱口而出了。但我马上接着说：不，但我爱你。哦，真好。所以你就像这档节目一样。有一点吧。
Yeah. Greg, thank you so much for coming on Office Ladies Today and talking about PDA. Well, thanks for having me. It's been so much fun to see you guys and reminisce again. All right. Well, we're going to be hitting you up for a few more episodes. Awesome. Well, we're back, it was so nice to see Greg.
是的。格雷格，非常感谢你今天来到《办公室女郎》并聊聊《办公室恋情》这一集。不客气，谢谢邀请。能看到你们并再次叙旧真是太有趣了。好吧。我们会为更多的剧集来找你的。太棒了。好了，我们回来了，见到格雷格真好。
I know. You know, before we start breaking down this episode, Angela, I realized I have some writer news that I didn't get to share. Okay. So beginning with this episode, writer and cast member BJ Novak was promoted. He was promoted from co-executive producer to executive producer and Warren Lieberstein and Halstead Sullivan were also promoted from producers to supervising producers. So we were handing out some promotions also.
我知道。你知道，在我们开始剖析这一集之前，安吉拉，我意识到我有一些关于编剧的新闻还没来得及分享。好吧。从这一集开始，编剧兼演员B·J·诺瓦克晋升了。他从联合执行制片人晋升为执行制片人，沃伦·李伯斯坦和霍尔斯特德·沙利文也从制片人晋升为监督制片人。所以我们当时也颁发出了一些晋升名额。
We kind of talked about this with Greg, but Robert Padnick, the writer for this episode was a new writer for season seven and he was nominated for a Writers Guild Award for this episode. I have a Robert Padnick story. I sold a show with Robert after the office. I remember that. Jenna, I went to my digital clutter because I was like, oh, do I have a synopsis or a log line about our show?
我们跟格雷格聊过这个，但罗伯特·帕德尼克，这一集的编剧，是第七季的新编剧，他因为这一集被提名了美国编剧工会奖。我有一个关于罗伯特·帕德尼克的故事。我在《办公室》之后和一个节目卖给罗伯特一个项目。我记得。珍娜，我翻找了我的数字杂物堆，因为我想：哦，我有没有关于我们节目的剧情梗概或一句话简介（logline）？
And I found it. Oh, share. Robert and I pitched this show. It did not end up getting made. It was briefly bought, but then didn't get made. And here's the log line, a family in which everyone is single and overly involved in each other's lives. Angela is trying to manage a house full of misfits while they all try to manage her
我找到了。哦，分享一下。罗伯特和我推销了这个节目。它最后没有被拍成。它曾短暂被买下，但后来没拍。这是当时的一句话简介：一个家庭，每个人都是单身，而且过度介入彼此的生活。安吉拉试图管理一个住满怪咖的房子，而他们所有人都在试图管理她的约会生涯。
dating career. Angela's unique blend of mothering instincts plus total naivete when it comes to dating gets her into compromising situations with the guy she meets. Angela works with her best friend, Jenna, whose own family serves as a counterpoint to Angela's and she lives vicariously through Angela's dating misadventures. Well, I want everybody to know how very hard it is to sell a show. That is not easy. I know this show didn't get made, but the fact that you have sold your shows that you've
安吉拉将她独有的母性本能与在约会方面的绝对天真完美结合，这让她与她遇到的男人陷入了妥协（尴尬）的境地。安吉拉和她最好的朋友珍娜一起工作，珍娜自己的家庭构成了对安吉拉家庭的对照，她通过安吉拉坎坷的约会经历过着一种代入式的生活。好吧，我想让所有人都知道，卖掉一个节目有多么难。那可不容易。我知道这个节目没被拍成，但事实上，当你出去推销时，你已经卖出了你推销过的节目，安吉拉很会推销，她是个伟大的编剧，伟大的创作者。
pitched when you go out to pitch Angela's sells, she's a great writer, great creator. Aw, thanks. I actually had a lot of fun rereading it. Well, let's get into this episode. We're going to start with this cold open of Pam presenting Daryl with a card. We find out that his grandmother has passed away, everyone has signed the card. Pam just wanted to deliver it. Well, as Daryl starts reading the card, it's clear that his coworkers didn't even read
啊，谢谢。我其实重读它时觉得挺有意思的。好吧，让我们进入这一集吧。我们要从这个冷开场开始，帕姆给达里尔送了一张卡片。我们发现他的祖母去世了，大家都在这张卡片上签了名。帕姆只是想把它送过去。好吧，当达里尔开始读卡片时，很明显他的同事们根本连卡片都没看，他们只是写了生日祝福。
the card and they just wrote birthday messages. Yeah. It's kind of a downer. Yeah. I mentioned there was a DVD commentary and on it, Greg shared that the idea of Daryl's tear was something that they came up with right on the spot. On the set, in the moment, they put some stuff in Craig's eye to help him tear up and then he looked at camera at the end and it was the perfect button.
有点扫兴。是的。我提到过有一个DVD评论音轨，格雷格在上面分享说，达里尔流的那滴眼泪是他们当场想出来的点子。在片场，在那个时刻，他们在克雷格的眼睛里弄了点东西帮他流泪，然后他在最后看了一眼镜头，这是个完美的点睛之笔。
I should say, in addition to Greg and myself on the DVD commentary, there's also Kelly Cantley, Ellie, Brian and Robert Padnick and I'll be sharing a few things from it along the way. Getting into the episode, we only had to sit through nine seconds of opening credits. Fast. Very fast because there was a lot we wanted to fit into this episode. There's several love stories. Right away, Andy's going to tell Daryl that he's talking to Rachel, you know?
我应该说，除了DVD评论音轨上的格雷格和我自己之外，还有凯莉·坎特利、埃莉、布莱恩和罗伯特·帕德尼克，我会在过程中分享一些来自那上面的内容。进入这一集，我们只需要看9秒钟的片头字幕。超快。非常快，因为有太多内容我们想塞进这一集里。有几条爱情线。一上来，安迪就告诉达里尔他在跟雷切尔聊天，你知道吗？
He met her at Daryl's party and he's going to be taking her out to dinner at Blue Wasabi. Yeah. Phyllis says they'll make a burger for you if you cause a scene. Yeah. She kind of throws that away. It's kind of like tucked under. Well, we got a fan question from Daria R in Ontario, Canada, who said, Blue Wasabi is a sushi restaurant in Clark's Summit, Pennsylvania.
他在达里尔的派对上遇到了她，他要带她去蓝芥末（Blue Wasabi）餐厅吃晚饭。是的。菲利斯说如果你闹事的话他们会为你做一个汉堡。是的。她有点随口说出这句话。有点像藏在后面。好吧，我们收到了来自加拿大安大略省达里娅·R的粉丝提问，她说：蓝芥末是宾夕法尼亚州克拉克萨米特的一家寿司餐厅。
It is now permanently closed, but it looks like they don't make burgers. So it's funny that Phyllis mentioned that you have to make a scene to get one. I'll have you know, there is a Blue Wasabi in Gilbert, Arizona that does have a Buddha burger on their menu. So you can get a burger at that Blue Wasabi, but not at the one in Pennsylvania that is now closed. Well, maybe Phyllis went there and made a big all scene and now it's on the menu. Perhaps Phyllis has been to Arizona.
它现在已经永久关门了，但看起来他们并不做汉堡。所以菲利斯提到你得闹事才能点到一个汉堡，这就很搞笑。我得告诉你们，亚利桑那州吉尔伯特市确实有一家蓝芥末，他们的菜单上有一个佛陀汉堡。所以你可以在那家蓝芥末买到汉堡，但在现在关门的那家宾夕法尼亚州的店里不行。好吧，也许菲利斯去过那里并且大闹了一场，现在它才上了菜单。也许菲利斯去过亚利桑那州。
We're going to start. The whole reason this episode was titled PDA with Michael and Holly, they're kissing each other goodbye before they go back to their respective deaths. They can't get enough of each other. They even do this little shimmy kiss hug all the way back to Michael's office. I want you to know that was improvised, the shimmy kiss. That was just even Amy having some fun there. That backward scoot was my personal favorite.
我们要开始了。这一集以迈克尔和霍莉命名为《办公室恋情》（PDA）的全部原因，就是他们在各自走回工位之前亲吻彼此告别。他们对彼此依依不舍。他们甚至一路亲亲抱抱地摇摆着回到迈克尔的办公室。我想让你们知道，那个摇摆亲吻是即兴发挥的。那只是艾美在那儿自得其乐。那个倒退的小碎步是我个人的最爱。
And I think if you look at one minute 52 seconds, you can kind of see Ed Helms starting to break. I'm sure. Because we weren't expecting it. And it was amazing. They would do different things each time. I caught us breaking throughout this whole episode. I believe it.
我想如果你看1分52秒，你大概能看到埃德·赫尔姆斯开始笑场。肯定的。因为我们没料到。这太棒了。他们每次都会做不同的动作。我发现在整集的播放过程中我们都在笑场。我信。
Next up, Erin is going to get a beautiful bouquet of flowers from Gabe. And when she opens the card, she realizes that there is going to be a romantic treasure hunt, not to be confused with a scavenger hunt. This is a treasure hunt. Yeah. Gabe has a talking head that says, I dominate Valentine's Day. I practically make romance into a science. On the commentary, Greg shared that his note to Zach for this talking head was, imagine
接下来，艾琳将收到盖比送来的一束美丽的花，当她打开卡片时，她意识到将有一场浪漫的寻宝游戏，注意，不要和寻宝游戏（scavenger hunt）混淆了。这是一场寻宝游戏（treasure hunt）。是的。盖比有一个单人访谈（talking head），说：我统治着情人节。我简直把浪漫变成了一门科学。在评论音轨上，格雷格分享说，他给扎克关于这个单人访谈的笔记是：想象他就像一个UFC格斗手，像一个综合格斗运动员，向他的另一个对手叫板那样。我统治着情人节。
he was like a UFC fighter, like a mixed martial artist, kind of calling out to his other opponent. I dominate Valentine's Day. Erin's first clue is a puzzle. She's going to have to put this puzzle together to figure out the next step in the treasure hunt. We got a fan question from Laura W. in La Crosse, Washington, related to the puzzle that Erin and Andy are putting together. Laura says, when I was in college, I worked a lot of random odd jobs and one of them was
艾琳的第一个线索是一个拼图。她必须把这个拼图拼好，才能找出寻宝游戏的下一步。我们收到了来自华盛顿州拉克罗斯的劳拉·W的粉丝提问，关于艾琳和安迪正在拼的拼图。劳拉说：上大学时，我做过很多零工，其中之一就是为华盛顿州拉克罗斯当地一家微型定制拼图厂工作。这是一家家族经营的企业。他们人超级好。有一次，我们在问老板他接过的最奇怪的定制拼图是什么。
for a tiny custom puzzle making facility right here in La Crosse, Washington. It's a family owned and run business. They are the sweetest people. At one point, we were quizzing the owner on his weirdest custom puzzles. And he said, they've gotten to make a few famous puzzles, including the one for this episode of The Office. Hey! Laura says, Wisconsin doesn't get a lot of movie magic opportunities, so shout out
他说，他们制作过一些著名的拼图，包括《办公室》这一集里的那个。嘿！劳拉说：威斯康星州没有太多电影特效的机会，所以向肖像拼图（Portrait Puzzles）致敬！耶！我们的布景设计师迈克尔·盖伦伯格拍了三张照片，菲尔·谢伊用肖像拼图制作了三个不同的拼图。然后格雷格选了他最喜欢的那个。
to Portrait Puzzles. Yes! Our set designer, Michael Gallenberg, took three photos and Phil Shea used portrait puzzles to make three different puzzles. Then Greg got to choose the one he liked best. The company Portrait Puzzles have been in business since 2005. They still make custom puzzles today, anywhere from 16-piece postcard puzzles to 30-piece puzzles, 1,000-piece puzzles.
肖像拼图这家公司自2005年开始营业。他们今天仍然制作定制拼图，从16片明信片拼图到30片拼图、1000片拼图应有尽有。他们运送到美国和加拿大，价格从29.99美元到49.99美元不等。啊！我们需要一个“办公室女郎”的拼图！我喜欢这个主意！肖像拼图，我们可能要打电话联系你们了。好吧，珍娜，我翻看了我们拍摄这一集那一周的数字杂物堆。好吧。
They ship to the US and Canada, and they range in price from $29.99 to $49.99. Aw! We need an office lady's puzzle! I like this idea! Portrait Puzzles, we might be calling you. Well, Jenna, I looked into my digital clutter for the week that we filmed this episode. Okay. We were emailing each other.
我们在互相发邮件。关于什么？你想听吗？是的！这把我逗乐得不行。好吧，这是我们的邮件往来。首先，我给你发邮件说：嘿，我今晚要尝试做一道新的晚餐食谱。这是我要做的。辣虾椰香饭。
About what? You want to hear? Yeah! This tickled me so much. All right, here is our email exchange. First, I emailed you, and I said, hey, I'm going to try a new recipe for dinner tonight. Here's what I'm making. Spicy shrimp coconut rice.
然后我把食谱发给你了。哦！你回信问：你打算做得有多辣？我回信说：挺辣的。我知道我们俩真像两个混蛋。然后我给你发邮件说：嘿，我在片场，帕特里斯拿着你的《红皮书》杂志。所以帕特里斯是我们的片场医疗人员。你一走进来，她就坐在后门旁边。
And then I sent you the recipe. Oh! You wrote back, how spicy are you making it? I wrote back and said, pretty spicy. I know we're such jerks. Then I wrote you, and I said, hey, I'm on set, and Patrice has your red book. So Patrice was our set medic. She sat right by the back door as you walked in.
珍娜，你是《红皮书》杂志的封面人物，帕特里斯买下了它，我给你发邮件说：我刚看了你的采访。太棒了，后面有三个感叹号。我觉得这是一次太棒的采访，你看起来棒极了。哦，天哪！于是我去寻找《红皮书》杂志的封面。珍娜，你看起来太美了。我要把它发到快拍里。
Jenna, you were on the cover of Red Book Magazine, and Patrice had bought it, and I wrote you, and I said, I just read your interview. That is great, three exclamation points. I felt like it was such an awesome interview, and you look fantastic. Oh my gosh! So then I went and looked for the cover of the Red Book Magazine. Jenna, you look amazing. I'm going to put it in stories.
文章写道：珍娜·菲舍尔，坦诚率真，超级可爱。这是由作家洛瑞·桑德尔撰写的采访的开篇段落。我得对我的闺蜜大加赞赏一番，因为我觉得这太可爱了。这是洛瑞写到与你见面时的情景。珍娜·菲舍尔的引言：“我和丈夫的相识故事听起来像是古怪的独立爱情电影的情节，这很贴切，因为他们正是在拍摄一部独立电影时坠入爱河的。”我在比弗利山庄酒店吃晚餐时听取了所有细节。珍娜吃的是通心粉配牛小排，我吃的是金枪鱼塔塔。
The article read, Jenna Fisher, totally candid and too cute. And this was the opening paragraph of the interview written by the writer, Lori Sandel. I have to gush on my BFF because I thought it was so adorable. This was what Lori wrote about meeting you. Jenna Fisher's quote, How I Met My Husband Story, sounds like the plot of a quirky indie romance, which is fitting since they fell in love while working on one. I'm hearing all the details over dinner at the Beverly Hills Hotel. Riga Tony was short ribs for Jenna, tuna tartare for me.
她比采访时间早到了五分钟——在名人世界里这简直闻所未闻——带着灿烂的笑容径直走向我，那样子仿佛正要向我咨询关于宝石的难题。珍娜穿着正装裤、灰色开衫和一件漂亮的红色衬衫，看起来就像两勺香草冰淇淋一样充满美国风情。当我们开始畅谈爱情、命运和最喜欢的指甲油颜色时——括号里写着：她非常喜欢埃茜（Essie）的安哥拉开衫——我不得不不断提醒自己，其实我并不认识她。她太随和了。
She arrived five minutes early for the interview, unheard of in the celebrity world, walking right over to me with a wide smile like she might be about to ask my advice on a gem dilemma. In dress pants, a gray cardigan, and a pretty red blouse, Jenna looks as all-American as two scoops of vanilla ice cream. And as we start to dish about love, fate, and favorite nail polish colors, parentheses, she's loving Essie's Angora Cardi. I have to keep reminding myself that I don't actually know her. She's so laid back.
她完全可以假装成你在高中的好朋友，就像在《办公室》里一样。哦，天哪！我知道！我那天留下了好印象。好吧，读到这里让我笑了，因为你就是那样的人，珍娜。你确实给人感觉像每个人的最好朋友，因为你就是这样一个友善、仁慈的人，而且你只是……你今天为什么把我弄哭了？
She could easily pass for your fun friend from high school, just like on the office. My gosh! I know! I made a good impression that day. Well, reading that made me smile because that's exactly who you are, Jenna. You do feel like everyone's best friend because you're just such a nice, kind person, and you just... Why are you making me cry today?
这到底是怎么回事？发生了什么？我是不是……我是不是要死了？没有！这是我的追悼会吗？别这样！这也太好了。别这样！
What is happening? What is going on? Am I... am I dying? No! Is this my memorial? Stop it! This is so kind. Stop it!
哦，天哪！我只是真的很高兴洛瑞写了那些，因为这就是我的真实感受。我完全没料到。我当时只是准备好谈论奥斯卡看着迈克尔和霍莉进行手部性爱（hand sex）的那个场景。一些剧烈的手部抚摸？是的。谢谢。
Oh my gosh! I just was really happy that Lori wrote that because that's how I feel. I was not expecting that. I was just ready to talk about the scene of Oscar watching Michael and Holly do some hand sex. Some heavy hand petting? Yes. Thank you.
谢谢你把它翻出来。我其实完全记得做那个采访。我太喜欢她了。她人太好了。她也让人感觉像是个一见如故的朋友，所以，你知道，她一定带着温暖走进采访，那让人卸下防备，我们度过了一个美好的晚餐。好吧，我会在快拍里发你的封面照片和那篇文章。
Thanks for digging that out. I actually completely remember doing that interview. I loved her. She was so nice. She felt like an instant friend too. So, you know, she must have come into the interview with a warmth and it was disarming, and we had a lovely dinner. Well, I'm going to put the photo and stories of you on the cover and the article.
我还要发我那个辣虾椰香饭的食谱。请一定要发。我喜欢我当时问的问题有多辣。嗯哼。真的很辣。那是发短信之前的年代。现在我们只会直接给对方发短信了。我知道。
And I'm also going to put my spicy shrimp coconut recipe. Please do. I love my question was how spicy. Mm-hmm. Real spicy. That was before texting. Now we would just text each other. I know.
而且我还要把我的辣虾椰子食谱放进去。请务必放进去。我很喜欢，我的问题是到底有多辣。嗯哼。非常辣。那是发短信之前的年代了。现在我们直接发短信联系了。我懂。
You guys, this is when we had flip phones. I love it. Well, now a very giggly Pam and Jim are going to arrive to the office via a cab. They are completely tooted. It's true. We had a fan question from Rachelle R. in El Dorado, California, who said, please help settle a decades-long friendly debate between my husband and I. My husband insists that you all are just incredibly talented actors, but come on.
77|||你们大家，这是我们用翻盖手机的年代。我太喜欢了。好吧，现在，非常兴奋且咯咯笑个不停的帕姆和吉姆将坐着出租车到达办公室。他们完全喝高了。确实如此。我们收到了来自加州埃尔多拉多市的蕾切尔·R.（Rachelle R.）的一个粉丝提问，她说，请帮我解决我和我丈夫之间长达数十年的友好争论。我丈夫坚称你们所有人只是演技极其出色的演员，但拜托。
You and John were really drunk, right? Don't worry. Your secret is safe with me. Rachelle, we were totally sober. They were totally sober. They just flip and crushed it. I have to brag on you one second here. What is happening?
你和约翰当时真的喝醉了吧？别担心。你的秘密对我来说是安全的。蕾切尔，我们完全是清醒的。他们完全是清醒的。他们只是超级厉害地完成了表演。我必须在这里夸你一秒钟。这是在干什么？
Well, listen now. I said this on the commentary and as I rewatched and heard myself from years ago, I agreed with myself, which is it's one thing to have to play drunk in one scene. That's hard enough. You had to play drunk all week, all week, and you had to match the same tone. We also had a long conversation about how it feels to day-drink and be a little tooted, as you would say, and then you're slowly sobering up. You know the kind of like, it doesn't feel great about three hours after you've done
好吧，现在听我说。我在评论音轨里说过这个，当我重看并听到多年前的自己时，我赞同了我自己，那就是：在一场戏里假装喝醉是一回事。这就够难的了。你得一整周都装作喝醉，整周都在喝醉状态，而且你还得保持相同的语调。我们还进行了一场长 conversa，关于白天喝酒并有点喝高——正如你所说的那样——然后慢慢清醒过来的感觉是什么样的。你知道那种感觉，在你白天喝酒大约三个小时后，感觉其实不太好。
day-drinking. You're kind of tired. It kind of ends in a nap. But that moment by the cab where Pam drops her scarf, I guess I'm going to pat myself on the back now. That was my idea on the day. So originally in the script, it was scripted that Jim was going to have a hard time counting the cash to the cab driver.
你会觉得有点累。它通常以一个小睡结束。但在出租车旁帕姆掉落围巾的那个瞬间，我想我现在要拍拍自己的肩膀夸夸自己了。那是当天临时想出的点子。所以原本在剧本中，剧本写的是吉姆在向出租车司机数现金时会遇到困难。
That was how we were going to reveal that we were kind of drunk and we were giggling because Jim couldn't count his money. But Greg wanted to move the camera into an extreme spy shot where they're really catching us through the upstairs window. Oh, so you wouldn't see the counting. It wasn't reading. So we had to come up with something else because Greg really didn't want us to see the camera. He didn't want the camera down in the parking lot.
那是我们原本用来表明我们有点喝醉、因为吉姆数不清钱而咯咯发笑的方式。但格雷格想把镜头移到一个极端的偷拍视角，从楼上的窗户真正地捕捉到我们。哦，所以你看不到数钱的动作。那没有传达出来。所以我们必须想别的办法，因为格雷格真的不想让我们看到摄像机。他不想让摄像机出现在停车场。
So I am always dropping stuff like that when I have had a couple of drinks. So like in New York City, if Lee and I go out to dinner and I have a couple of glasses of wine, you can count on me leaving a glove or my scarf or something on the side of the road or in a taxi. So I pitched this idea and I managed to drop the scarf and that whole bit, we kind of found that on the day I'm really proud of it. It completely sells it. Also the way you stood back up, like you could tell things got a little dizzy for you.
所以我喝了几杯酒后总是会掉东西。比如在纽约市，如果我和李出去吃晚饭，我喝了几杯葡萄酒，你就可以指望我把手套、围巾或其他什么东西落在路边或出租车里。所以我提出了这个想法，我设法把围巾掉了下来，整个桥段，我们算是在当天碰出来的，我为此感到非常自豪。它完全把那种状态演活了。还有你重新站起来的方式，你可以看出你有点头晕目眩。
Yes. Yes. This next storyline really sets up Andy and Erin for the whole day. Erin is going to ask Andy to help her with her scavenger hunt. It's a treasure hunt. You know, I think I'm more on Erin's side on this. I think it is a scavenger hunt. What's the difference?
是的。是的。接下来的这条故事线真正为安迪和艾琳这一整天做了铺垫。艾琳要请求安迪帮她完成寻宝游戏。这是一场寻宝。你知道的，我觉得在这件事上我更倾向于艾琳这一边。我觉得这是一个寻宝游戏（Scavenger hunt）。有什么区别？
Oh, I know the difference. What? The scavenger hunt is when you have a piece of paper and you have all these different things you have to check off. So you've given those to your kids before, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
哦，我知道区别。什么？寻宝游戏（Scavenger hunt）是指你手里有一张纸，上面列着你要勾选的各种不同的东西。所以你以前给你的孩子们玩过那种，对吧？对。对。对。
So that's a scavenger hunt because you're collecting multiple items or you're checking off multiple items like find some sticks, find a rock, find a penny, find a leaf that's orange. And it all builds into a little hut at the end. Well, it builds into nothing. That's the point. The treasure hunt is one clue after another leading to an ultimate treasure, a single item.
所以那是寻宝游戏（Scavenger hunt），因为你在收集多件物品，或者你在勾选多件物品，比如找一些树枝、找一块石头、找一分钱、找一片呈橙色的叶子。而这一切最终都汇聚成一个小棚屋。嗯，它什么也没汇聚成。这就是重点。寻宝（Treasure hunt）是一条接一条的线索，通往最终的宝藏，也就是单一的物品。
Oh, well. Okay. So whatever it is, it's a lot of work. It is. If you go to four minutes, 19 seconds, Andy is going to say, okay, fine, at least until Stanley calms down. And Erin's like, oh, is he? And Andy's like, don't look.
哦，好吧。好吧。不管它是什么，这都是一项巨大的工程。确实是。如果你跳到4分19秒，安迪会说，好吧，好吧，至少等到斯坦利冷静下来。然后艾琳说，哦，是吗？安迪说，别看。
I accidentally did his Sudoku. And then there's the shot of Stanley glaring at Andy. That was all scripted. Robert said he wrote this moment for his mom. He said his mom loves the character of Stanley and Sudoku. And he wanted to make sure that there was a funny Stanley moment in the script. He had been thinking about it from the day he was told he was going to work on the office. That is so sweet.
我一不小心帮他把数独给填了。然后镜头切到斯坦利怒视安迪。这全都是剧本里写好的。罗伯特说他写这个时刻是为了他的妈妈。他说他妈妈很喜欢斯坦利的这个角色以及数独。他想确保剧本里有一个搞笑的斯坦利时刻。自从他被告知要来《办公室》工作的那天起，他就一直在考虑这件事。这太甜了。
I know. Oh my gosh. I love that that moment was for his mom. Yeah. Two of her favorite things, Stanley and Sudoku. Jim is now going to give Dwight a little Valentine. You know, like those ones that you buy for your kids and they're perforated and they're little squares and sometimes they come with candy.
我知道。哦天哪。我好喜欢那个时刻是为他妈妈写的这件事。是的。她最喜欢的两样东西，斯坦利和数独。吉姆现在要给德怀特一个小情人节卡片。你知道的，就像那种你买给孩子们的、带齿孔的、一小格一小格的、有时还附带糖果的卡片。
I guess Jim's handing those out because he's a little tipsy. But in deleted scenes, there was a bigger moment here. Jim goes on to give Dwight a compliment and we find out what Dwight finds funny. Oh, here it is. You know Dwight, I don't tell you this enough, but I think you're really funny. Thank you. You're welcome. I'm not known for my sense of humor.
我猜吉姆在分发那些东西，因为他有点微醺。但在删减片段中，这里有一个更大的情节。吉姆接着给了德怀特一个赞美，我们得知了德怀特觉得什么东西有趣。哦，在这里。你知道德怀特，我没有足够经常地对你说这个，但我认为你真的很有趣。谢谢你。不客气。我不以幽默感闻名。
That would appall me. But I have one. I find inversions of fortune funny, upside down houses, how a man spends his hard earned money on art, how a map distorts the size of Antarctica. Tickling always makes me laugh. Tickling. Tickling. I like that he would be appalled if he was known as funny.
那会让我感到震惊。但我确实有一个。我觉得命运的逆转很有趣，比如颠倒的房子、一个男人如何把辛苦赚来的钱花在艺术上、地图如何扭曲南极洲的大小。胳肢总是能让我笑出声。胳肢。胳肢。我喜欢他如果被称为有趣会感到震惊这一点。
So now we're going to go to the break room and, Angela, you have a very interesting line here. Mm-hmm. We got some mail about it. Oh. This scene starts with Angela saying, I don't know if anyone else feels this way and don't get me wrong. I love Michael and Holly and maybe I'm being overly sensitive, but the PDA.
所以现在我们要去茶水间了，安吉拉，你在这里有一句非常有趣的台词。嗯-hmm。我们收到了一些关于它的邮件。哦。这个场景以安吉拉说的话开始：“我不知道是不是还有其他人有这种感觉，别误会我。我爱迈克尔和霍莉，也许是我太敏感了，但是那个公开秀恩爱（PDA）……”
Yes. And for once, her and Oscar are on the same page. She's like, yes, the PDA. Oh, everyone's so glad she brought it up. Well, we had a fan question from Becca in North Thumberland, England, who said, is it me or is Angela kind of out of character in the break room when she says, don't get me wrong? Since when has Angela ever added a caveat to her opinions?
是的。而且破天荒地，她和奥斯卡意见完全一致。她说：“没错，那个公开秀恩爱（PDA）……”哦，每个人都高兴她把这事挑明了。好吧，我们收到了来自英格兰诺森伯兰郡的贝卡的一个粉丝提问，她说，是我个人的问题，还是安吉拉在茶水间里说“别误会我”的时候有点不太符合她的人设？安吉拉什么时候对自己的看法加上过保留条件？
I have to agree. You are being like so diplomatic in that moment. Yeah. I agree, Becca. You know, if you listen to the commentary, we have a conversation about this. And Greg brings up the fact that one of the things he told me when I auditioned for the role of Angela was he said she's the type of person that would say, well, I would never say anything about them, but, and you know it's coming.
我不得不赞同。那一刻你表现得太外交辞令了。是的。我同意，贝卡。你知道，如果你听评论音轨，我们会对此进行一番讨论。格雷格提到，当初我为安吉拉这个角色试镜时，他对我说过的一句话是：她就是那种会说“嗯，我绝不会对他们评头论足，但是……”这样的人，而且你知道接下来准没好事。
So I think this was on theme a little bit for who she is, but there is the sassy Angela that might have just said enough with the PDA. Well, I feel like she might say that to their faces, but when she is leading the group discussion, she is, I don't know. She also wants the group on her side, so maybe she has to start out with a little bit of honey. Listen, we had another fan question from Jade M in Paris, France, who said, this was a really complicated episode for Europeans to follow because we do not know what PDA means.
所以我认为这在一定程度上符合她的人设，但也有那个可能只会说“受够了公开秀恩爱（PDA）”的那个刻薄的安吉拉。嗯，我觉得她可能会当面那样对他们说，但当她在领导集体讨论时，她……我不知道。她也想把大家拉到她这一边，所以也许她不得不先用一点甜头开个场。听着，我们收到了来自法国巴黎的杰德·M.的另一个粉丝提问，她说，这对欧洲人来说是一个非常难懂的插曲，因为我们不知道PDA是什么意思。
Not even Gabe in the conference room explains PDA. Oh my gosh. Now I know it means public display of affection, but my partner and I had to look for the meaning on the internet and then it suddenly made so much sense with all the Michael and Holly kissing. I never even saw that. Me either. Well, Jade, the PDA is going to continue.
甚至连会议室里的盖布都没有解释PDA是什么意思。哦天哪。现在我知道它的意思是“当众亲热”（public display of affection），但我和伴侣不得不上网去查它的意思，然后突然之间，所有迈克尔和霍莉接吻的画面就全都合情合理了。我甚至从来没注意到那个。我也是。好吧，杰德，公开秀恩爱（PDA）还将继续。
It's going to level up even. We should probably go to break because when we get back, Gabe's going to have a meeting about it. We're back from break and Gabe says, seeing as it's Valentine's Day, maybe we should have an impromptu meeting about romance in the workplace. Yeah, we pan around the room and Michael is sitting in Holly's lap and she has her arms underneath his underarms and she's sort of doing that thing where she is his arms, but she's also rubbing his chest.
它甚至还要升级。我们大概应该去休息一下，因为当我们回来时，盖布要开一个关于这个主题的会议。我们从课间休息回来，盖布说，既然今天是情人节，也许我们应该就职场中的浪漫开一个即兴会议。是的，镜头扫过整个房间，迈克尔坐在霍莉的腿上，她的手臂穿过他的腋下，她有点在做那种既当他的手臂、又在揉他胸口的事情。
Yeah, it's like Michael body, Holly arms. Yes. Did you notice where Angela Martin is sitting? Where? Right next to them. That must have been so difficult. They did that on purpose. On either side is Kevin who's really into it and Angela who's completely grossed out
对，就像迈克尔的身体，霍莉的手臂。是的。你注意到安吉拉·马丁坐在哪里了吗？哪里？就在他们旁边。那一定很难熬。他们是故意那样做的。两边分别是真正乐在其中的凯文，以及对此感到超级恶心……
by it. Jim and Pam are in the back corner. We had another fan catch from Daria R. in Ontario, Canada who said at six minutes and 50 seconds, Pam does a huge yawn in the background and then again at seven minutes and 40 seconds. Yes, Daria. My yawns were scripted. That is what we talked about. That is drunk Pam who's coming down from her buzz, I guess.
……的安吉拉。吉姆和帕姆坐在后排角落。我们收到了来自加拿大安大略省达里亚·R.的另一个粉丝抓包，她说在6分50秒时，帕姆在背景里打了一个大大的哈欠，然后在7分40秒时又打了一个。是的，达里亚。我打哈欠是剧本安排的。这就是我们讨论过的。那是喝醉的帕姆在酒劲消退，我猜。
I'm surprised she doesn't fall asleep. I know and she is tired. Well there is a joke coming up in the conference room. Greg mentioned it earlier and I had to give a shout out to the writer. When Kevin says she goes to another school, Robert Padnick shared that that joke was written by Danny Chun. Nice job, Danny. Michael and Holly are going to realize that this whole meeting is for them.
我很惊讶她没有睡着。我知道，而且她很累。好吧，会议室里即将有一个笑话。格雷格刚才提到了，我必须向编剧致敬。当凯文说“她去另一所学校了”时，罗伯特·帕德尼克透露这个笑话是丹尼·陈写的。干得好，丹尼。迈克尔和霍莉会意识到，整个会议全都是针对他们的。
They are the PDA that is making everyone uncomfortable. They are shocked to hear this as they're sitting on each other's laps, like touching each other. Yes. Shocked. Yes. Michael agrees, fine. No more PDA, instead we're going to designate an office closet as a hookup zone.
他们就是那个让所有人都感到不舒服的公开秀恩爱（PDA）。当他们坐在彼此膝盖上、互相抚摸时，听到这个消息，他们震惊了。是的。震惊。是的。迈克尔表示同意，好吧。再也没有公开秀恩爱了，取而代之的是，我们要指定一个办公室储藏室作为约会区。
Dwight mentions there's so many people who might be hooking up. Michael agrees, they're going to need three closets. My personal favorite moment here, this was totally scripted, is when Dwight says, what is your position on masturbation in the hookup closet? Michael takes a long pause and then says, pro. That was scripted. The pause was all Steve and the pause really sells it. You can see Michael thinking about it, pro.
德怀特提到有那么多人在约会。迈克尔表示同意，他们需要三个储藏室。我个人最喜欢的时刻，这完全是剧本写好的，是当德怀特问：“你对在约会储藏室里自慰有什么立场？”迈克尔停顿了很久，然后说：“赞成。”那是剧本写好的。停顿完全是史蒂夫的发挥，那个停顿真的把这个包袱抖响了。你可以看到迈克尔在考虑这件事，“赞成”。
Pro. There were so many things that made me laugh, like genuinely laugh out loud in this conference room. I'm phrasing when Dwight's like, as has Ryan, as has Kelly, as has Meredith, as has Phyllis, as has Darryl, as has Creed, as has Michael, as has Holly, as has Kevin, what Kevin yells. Yeah, this is when Jim and Pam realize they're really the only people who have not hooked up at work. Yeah.
赞成。有太多东西让我笑出声，在这个会议室里是真正的大笑。我组织一下语言，当德怀特说：“正如瑞安所做的那样，正如凯莉所做的那样，正如梅雷迪思所做的那样，正如菲利斯所做的那样，正如达里尔所做的那样，正如克里德所做的那样，正如迈克尔所做的那样，正如霍莉所做的那样，正如凯文……”凯文大喊大叫。是的，这就是吉姆和帕姆意识到他们真的是唯一没有在工作时约过会的人的时候。是的。
I can't tell if they're bummed out by it or just they feel like they need to be in the club. I don't know, Pam gets a B in her bonnet about it. She does. Before we go to the break room where she starts to muse about where they can hook up, everyone, please do yourself a favor. When Dwight says, as has Creed, please look at Creed's face, please. We talked about this scene a little bit with Greg.
我分不清他们对此是感到沮丧，还是只是觉得自己需要加入这个俱乐部。我不知道，帕姆脑子里突然冒出了一个古怪的念头。确实如此。在我们去茶水间之前，她开始沉思他们可以在哪里约会，各位，请帮自己一个忙。当德怀特说“正如克里德所做的那样”时，请看看克里德的脸，求你了。我们和格雷格稍微讨论过这个场景。
It's a wonderful spy shot of Jim and Pam in the break room and Pam is going to get the idea that her and Jim need to hook up at work. I think one of the things about this storyline that really works is that it does seem really driven by Pam. Yeah, and Jim's like, okay. This is a total TMI question. Okay. We don't have to share any details.
这是吉姆和帕姆在茶水间的一个精彩偷拍镜头，帕姆会产生一个想法，那就是她和吉姆需要在工作时约会。我认为这条故事线真正起作用的一点在于，它确实看起来是由帕姆极力推动的。是的，而吉姆的反应是：“好吧。”这是一个绝对属于“提供过多个人信息”（TMI）的问题。好吧。我们不需要分享任何细节。
Okay. Have you ever hooked up in a public place? Yes. I don't think I have. Oh, well. Well, well. Moving on. Take some tea.
好吧。你们曾经在公共场合约会过吗？是的。我觉得我没有。哦，好吧。好吧，好吧。继续。喝点茶吧。
Okay. Move on. Moving on, Erin has solved her puzzle and they have moved on to the second clue, which is on the boom box in Daryl's office. Craig as Daryl is so funny in this scene. He's like, pick it up, pick it up. I know. Pick it up, pick it up, pick it up.
好吧。继续。继续，艾琳已经解开了她的谜题，他们已经进入了第二个线索，线索在达里尔办公室的收音机上。克雷格饰演的达里尔在这场戏里太搞笑了。他说：“拿起来，拿起来。”我知道。拿起来，拿起来，拿起来。
They're just talking and he's trying to work at eight minutes and 58 seconds. We have a sticky quip callback. Did you notice the play me is on a sticky quip? It was also on the puzzle. I saw that as well. Also in the background over Andy's shoulder is a photo of Daryl and his daughter. It is clearly taken from the Christmas episode. And I just want to give a shout out to Michael Gallenberg.
他们只是在说话，而他在8分58秒时试图工作。我们有一个便签贴的回应。你注意到那个“玩我”是写在便签贴上的吗？谜题上也是。我也看到了。同样在背景里安迪肩膀上方的是一张达里尔和女儿的照片。它显然是从圣诞节那一集里截取的。我只想向迈克尔·盖伦伯格致敬。
He was always thinking ahead. He would grab people for photos and then he would give those photos to our set decoration team who would place them and personalize people's desks or save it if we ever were to go to Daryl's house. We would have that picture of Daryl and his daughter. It was just really smart. So we talked a little bit with Greg about these scenes where all of the B-roll of Jim and Pam trying to find the places to hook up and then of this really magical moment
他总是未雨绸缪。他会抓拍人们的照片，然后把这些照片交给我们的布景装饰团队，由他们把照片摆放好，个性化每个人的办公桌，或者留存以防我们去达里尔家。我们就会有那张达里尔和女儿的照片。这真的很聪明。所以我们和格雷格简单聊了聊这些场景，全都是吉姆和帕姆试图找到约会地点的B卷素材，然后是这个真正神奇的时刻：
where Michael and Holly realize they love each other and they tell each other in front of the whole bullpen and then shake on it. There's a very sweet Michael talking head afterwards. It's so good. I know. He says, yeah, whatever. No big deal. Just the hottest girl in the world loves me.
迈克尔和霍莉意识到他们相爱了，他们在整个员工大办公区前向彼此表白，然后击掌为誓。后面有一个非常温馨的迈克尔单人采访。太棒了。我知道。他说：“好吧，无所谓。没什么大不了的。只不过是世界上最辣的女孩爱上了我。”
Oh my gosh. I loved it. Kelly Cantley shared that NBC immediately put that talking head on a coffee mug. Really? Oh my goodness. I looked for it. I couldn't find it, but I did find that quote on several things online. Andy and Erin are going to go into Ryan's little clawfish.
我的天啊。我太喜欢了。凯利·坎特利分享说，全国广播公司立刻把那个特写镜头做成了咖啡杯。真的吗？哦，我的天哪。我找过。我没找到，但我确实在网上好几个地方找到了那句话。安迪和艾琳要走进莱恩的小龙虾窝了。
This is the next step in the treasure hunt. There are these little glow-in-the-dark sticky stars all over the wall, all over the ceiling. It's so cute. It's very romantic. Kelly shared on the DVD that the glow-in-the-dark stars were actually painted. Yes. Randy said that this was really hard to pull off and that the sticky stars were not showing up on camera when they tested it.
这是寻宝游戏的下一步。墙上、天花板上到处都是这种会发光的荧光小贴纸星星。太可爱了。非常浪漫。凯利在DVD上分享说，那些发光星星其实是画上去的。是的。兰迪说这真的很难搞定，而且他们测试时发现这些贴纸星星在镜头里根本显现不出来。
And I guess they had to paint over them with a bunch of extra, what do you call it, like glow-in-the-dark paint. Kelly said she thinks it was special paint like they use on the highway. Yes. And they also said that they had to add tons of extra ultraviolet lights, including a special ring light that went around the lens of the camera. Just so those would pop? Just so those would pop.
我想他们不得不涂上一层又一层额外的，你叫什么来着，就像夜光漆一样的东西。凯利说她觉得那是那种用在高速公路上的特殊油漆。是的。他们还说他们必须增加大量的紫外线灯，包括一个环绕相机镜头的特殊环形灯。就为了让它们显现出来？就为了让它们显现出来。
They popped in the room, but when they did a camera test of it, you didn't see it the way you wanted. So that was like a high effort gag. Oh my gosh. When I first saw it, I was like, oh, so cute. I have those in my daughter's room on the ceiling. Yeah. But no, highway paint, guys.
它们在房间里很显眼，但当他们做摄像测试时，并没有达到你想要的效果。所以那算是一个高成本的恶作剧。天哪。我第一次看到的时候，我就想，哦，太可爱了。我女儿房间的天花板上就有那些。是的。但不是，那是高速公路漆，伙计们。
Highway paint. This is Andy and Erin Exit, Ryan's little office. Jim and Pam, we're trying to get in there. They were going to have sex in Ryan's office, come on. I'm personally so glad that Ryan caught them because since, you know, I'm Pam, I really think we would have regretted having sex in Ryan's office. I feel like that's a memory that Jim and Pam did not need. Ryan's smug look about it too.
高速公路漆。这是安迪和艾琳离开莱恩的小办公室。吉姆和帕姆，我们正试图进去呢。他们本打算在莱恩的办公室里做爱，拜托。我个人真的很庆幸莱恩抓住了他们，因为你知道的，我是帕姆，我真的觉得我们会在莱恩的办公室里做爱而后悔。我觉得那是吉姆和帕姆不需要的记忆。莱恩对此的自鸣得意也让人讨厌。
Oh, Pam is like so embarrassed. It turns out that Michael and Holly not doing PDA is more annoying than PDA. Yeah. I love the scene where they are like air groping each other. I will touch you here, but I can't, so I will hold you here and I will touch you here. During this scene, we have our third catch from Daria R. in Ontario, Canada. Daria, thank you. You have quite the eye.
哦，帕姆尴尬极了。事实证明，迈克尔和霍利不做公开秀恩爱比秀恩爱还要烦人。是的。我喜欢他们隔空乱摸对方的那场戏。我会在这里摸你，但我不能，所以我会在那里抱你，我会在这里摸你。在这场戏中，我们迎来了来自加拿大安大略省的达里亚·R的第三条线索。达里亚，谢谢你。你真是好眼力。
You should be an honorary member of Office Ladies. And if anything, mom detectives. That's for sure. Daria says at 14 minutes and 30 seconds, we can see Angela watering the plants near Michael's office. Dwight used to water the plants in the office. Why is Angela doing it now? Is he lacking on his duties because of volunteering and doing so much as the building owner?
你应该成为办公室女士的名誉会员。如果一定要说的话，那就是妈妈侦探。那是肯定的。达里亚说在14分30秒时，我们可以看到安吉拉在迈克尔办公室附近浇花。德怀特以前负责办公室浇花。为什么现在是安吉拉在做？是因为他忙于做志愿者和作为大楼业主做了太多事而玩忽职守吗？
Did he assign the task to Angela? Will please speak to the plants? Well, I share on the commentary that I'm pruning the plants. Oh. I guess I started watering, then I pruned. By the end of the scene, because we did it so many times, I said I actually felt bad because I had pruned all the dead things off and then I just started picking up new leaves. Oh, no.
难道是他把这个任务分派给安吉拉了？请跟植物对话好吗？好吧，我在评论里分享过我在修剪植物。哦。我想我先是浇水，然后修剪。到了这场戏结束时，因为我们拍了太多次，我说我其实觉得挺内疚的，因为我把所有枯死的东西都修剪掉了，然后我开始摘新叶子。哦，不。
I felt bad. I love the idea that Dwight and Angela water the plants. It also makes you question, why did Pam's plant die? It doesn't make me question it. It seems very clear that Angela would not water a plant on Pam's desk. Well, Daria, they put me there by the plant because they wanted a wide range of reaction shots to Michael and Holly and you couldn't see me weighing that accounting nook, so they pulled me out to the plant.
我觉得很糟糕。我很喜欢德怀特和安吉拉浇花这个设定。这也让人产生疑问，为什么帕姆的植物会死？这并没有让我产生疑问。很明显，安吉拉是不会给帕姆办公桌上的植物浇水的。好吧，达里亚，他们把我安排在那里靠近植物的地方，因为他们想要捕捉对迈克尔和霍利的一系列反应镜头，而你在那个会计角落里看不到我，所以他们把我拉到了植物旁边。
You'll notice Darryl is at front reception as well. Well, I have, I guess, a Fisher tidbit. Oh. I haven't known where to bring it up, but maybe now's the time. You know I love a tidbit. Did you know that there is a restaurant called Public Display of Affection? It's in Brooklyn, New York and it is described as a trendy compact eatery serving creative pizzas, vegetable dishes, and salads plus beer.
你会注意到达里尔也在前台。好吧，我大概有一个关于费舍尔的花絮。哦。我一直不知道该怎么提起它，但也许现在是时候了。你知道我喜欢花絮。你知道有一家餐厅叫公开秀恩爱吗？它位于纽约布鲁克林，被描述为一家时髦紧凑的小餐馆，供应创意披萨、蔬菜菜肴、沙拉以及啤酒。
Do you feel like you would be obligated to engage in PDA at the restaurant Public Display of Affection? I'm curious. No. Have you ever encountered an awkward PDA moment? I mean, I don't know if it was so much awkward as just the proximity of me next to the person doing it. That feels awkward.
你觉得你在公开秀恩爱餐厅会有义务进行秀恩爱吗？我很好奇。没有。你有没有遇到过尴尬的秀恩爱时刻？我的意思是，与其说是尴尬，不如说是我离做这件事的人太近了。那感觉真尴尬。
Okay. Well, I also thought it was kind of sweet. Here's the deal. We were in line to get on a plane, me and Josh, and you know when you get in the, what is that thing that attaches from the side of the tarmac? The tarmac? No, not the tarmac. That's what the plane.
好吧。不过我也觉得挺甜蜜的。事情是这样的。我们当时正排队登机，我和乔希，你知道当你走进那个，从停机坪侧面连接的那个东西是什么？停机坪？不，不是停机坪。那是飞机……
Oh, that's what the plane is. The tunnel that's got the accordion door that attaches from the wall to the plane. We always call that the jetway, the jetway, the jet bridge. I know someone's going to write in and let us know what that's called. So when you're in that single file lane, and sometimes whoever's getting on the plane, if they're taking a while, you kind of get stuck in that corridor tunnel thingy. So we're stuck in the corridor tunnel thingy, and there was a couple in front of us. This was also a flight to Vegas.
哦，那是飞机。就是那个带有手风琴门、从墙壁连接到飞机的通道。我们总是把那个叫登机桥、登机桥、喷气式登桥。我知道会有人写信告诉我们那个叫什么。所以当你排成单行道时，有时候不管谁登机，如果他们花了一点时间，你就会被卡在那个走廊隧道里。所以我们被卡在走廊隧道里，我们前面有一对夫妇。这也是一趟去维加斯的航班。
Oh, maybe this is the tone, maybe this is the mood people were in. But the guy just kept putting his hand on her butt cheek and just giving it a little squeeze. But like, we take a few steps, he'd give her a little squeeze, then we'd take a few more steps, he'd give her a little squeeze. Well, I think we know what he was hoping would happen in Vegas. I think so. I have one that's sort of, it's an oral PDA.
哦，也许这就是这种基调，也许这就是人们当时的心情。但那个男的一直把手放在她的屁股上，然后捏了一下。但是，我们走几步，他又捏一下，然后我们再走几步，他又捏一下。好吧，我想我们知道他希望在维加斯发生什么了。我也这么觉得。我有一个差不多是这样的，那是口头秀恩爱。
What? So last year. What? Yeah, I was, you know, I was skiing with my family, but they're more advanced skiers than I am. So, my husband and two kids, they had taken off to do some blue and black runs. And I said, I'll stay here on the greens. So if you ski, you know that if you're a single, you can go to a special lane on the
什么？所以去年。什么？是的，我当时，你知道的，我和家人去滑雪，但他们比我滑得好。所以，我丈夫和两个孩子，他们去滑中级道和高级道了。我说，我留在这里滑初级道。所以如果你滑过雪，你就知道如果你是一个人，你可以去一个特殊的通道……
lift. Yeah, for singles. So if a group of three people come up and they need a fourth for the lift chair, you just hop on with them. Nothing made out on the lift chair? No. Hop on. It wasn't, it was, nobody made out on the lift chair, but I got added to a lift.
对，为单人准备的。所以如果三个人一组过来，他们需要第四个人来凑齐缆车座位，你就可以直接跟他们一起上。缆车上没有人卿卿我我吧？没有。直接上去。没有，没有人卿卿我我在缆车上，但我被加到一个缆车里了。
It was three singles. There was a man and then there was another man in the middle and then I was on the end. The guy in the middle gets a phone call. None of us are speaking, by the way. You know, we get a high, high, high quiet. We're on the lift. The guy in the middle gets a phone call. No.
那是三个单人。有一个男的，然后中间还有另一个男的，然后我在边缘。中间的那个人接了个电话。顺便说一句，我们谁也没说话。你知道的，我们保持着高度的安静。我们在缆车上。中间的那个人接了个电话。没有。
He answers it. And then does sexy talk? No. Oh. He described in great detail to the person on the other end, his hookup from the night before. Get out. Like play by play.
他接了。然后开始说性感的话？没有。哦。他向电话那头的人极其详细地描述了他前一晚的艳遇。少来。就像现场直播一样。
Oh my God, and you're just stuck there. You're just me and the other guy who are on either side of him. Total strangers. Yes. We kind of leaned back and gave each other a look like, wow, this is happening. Information, but also the guy in the middle, in addition to telling his whole hookup story, was like, and dude, I am still wasted. I'm still wasted.
天哪，而你只能被困在那里。我和另一个坐在他两侧的人。完全是陌生人。是的。我们有点往后靠，互相看了一眼，心想，哇，这正在发生。不仅有信息量，而且中间那个家伙，除了讲述他整个艳遇故事之外，还说，兄弟，我还是喝醉的状态。我还是喝醉的。
I am so like, I am drunk right now and we're thinking, what is going on? Why are you on a ski lift? So he gets off the ski lift and he turns to the guy next to him and says, how do I get to death drop? What? Do I go up to like the highest black and ski to, I was like, do I say, do I get a ranger? Can you report someone? I don't know whatever happened to that guy, but that was sort of like, that's an oral
我整个人就像，我现在喝醉了，而我们在想，这到底是怎么回事？你为什么在滑雪缆车上？所以他下了滑雪缆车，转向他旁边的人说，我怎么去死亡落差？什么？我是去最高的高级道然后滑向……我心想，我要说吗，我要找巡逻员吗？你可以举报别人吗？我不知道那个家伙后来怎么样了，但那有点像，那是口头的……
PDA that I was subjected to. I think you need a new term. What is it? Oral PDA is very off-putting. I don't know what to call it. I think it's a verbal PDA, verbal. I hear you. Yeah.
我遭受的公开秀恩爱。我觉得你需要一个新词。是什么？口头公开秀恩爱太让人反感了。我不知道该怎么称呼它。我觉得这是语言上的公开秀恩爱，语言上的。我懂你的意思。是的。
I hear you. It's got to be a verbal thing. An audio. Oh, huh. Oh. Audible PDA. And here's the thing. He had no idea he was sitting next to Pam from the office because you have goggles and
我懂你的意思。这必须是一个用声音表达的东西。一种有声的。哦，哈。哦。有声公开秀恩爱。事情是这样的。他根本不知道自己旁边坐着办公室里的帕姆，因为你戴着护目镜和面罩、帽子还有头盔，就像我一直隐姓埋名滑雪一样。我知道。太搞笑了。好吧，我真希望当时缆车上有盖布来叫这家伙闭嘴。这正是他在下一场戏里对迈克尔和霍利做的事情。他在告诉他们真的必须适可而止。是的。所以珍娜，在拍摄剧本中，当迈克尔、霍利和盖布上演这一幕时，
a mask and a hat and a helmet and it's like, I ski in anonymity all the time. I know. It's pretty funny. Well, I wish I had Gabe on the ski lift to tell this guy to cut it out. That's exactly what he's doing in the next scene with Michael and Holly. He's telling them they really have to cut it out. Yeah. So Jenna, in the shooting draft, while this scene is going on with Michael and Holly and
在办公区里，每个人都在对迈克尔和霍利评头论足。好吧。就像是，这太过分了。他们做得太过了。奥斯卡打算问问吉姆和帕姆的想法，因为他们坐在那里一言不发。这场戏太棒了。它在被删减片段里。这可能是我最喜欢的吉姆和帕姆喝醉的戏。
Gabe, back in the bullpen, everyone is kind of trash talking about Michael and Holly. Okay. Like, this is too much. They've taken it too far. And Oscar is going to ask Jim and Pam their thoughts because they're sitting there quiet. The scene is so great. It's in deleted scenes. It's maybe my favorite drunk Jim and Pam scene.
哦，天哪。它在被删减片段里。我想让你听听。然后我必须把它发到我们的快拍里，因为它太贴切了。给你听。也许我们对迈克尔和霍利有点过头了，我的意思是，真的，他们有那么糟糕吗？哦，是的。
Oh, my goodness. It's in deleted scenes. I want you to hear it. And then I have to put it in our stories because it's so spot on. Here it is. Maybe we went a little overboard on Michael and Holly, I mean, really, were they that bad? Oh, yes.
They were horrible. Jim, Pam, wouldn't you agree that PDA in any form is inappropriate for the office? Jim stands up to make a speech. He starts rolling up his sleeves. Pam starts rolling up her sleeves. Jim stands up. Everybody's points. Really excellent.
太可怕了。吉姆，帕姆，你们不觉得任何形式的办公室公开秀恩爱都很不得体吗？吉姆站起来准备演讲。他开始卷起袖子。帕姆开始卷起袖子。吉姆站起来。大家的观点。真的很棒。
And I think, at the end of the day, what we have to remember definitely is what is reasonable. No, I think that the most important thing is to just ignore everything he said. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I love him. He doesn't matter. I love him. That's okay.
而且我认为，归根结底，我们绝对要记住的是什么才是合理的。不，我认为最重要的是忽略他所说的一切。我开玩笑呢。我开玩笑呢。我爱他。这不重要。我爱他。没关系。
It's just, it's 100%. 100%. 100% what? 100% what? What are you talking about? Hey, idiot twins, 100% what? What are you talking about? You didn't answer the question.
这只是，100%。100%。100%什么？100%什么？你在说什么？嘿，笨蛋双人组，100%什么？你在说什么？你没有回答问题。
Do you feel stifled by our rules against public displays of affection? Yes. No. No. No. No. I think we should take a vote. What are we voting for?
你们觉得我们禁止公开秀恩爱的规定让人感到窒息吗？是的。不。不。不。不。我认为我们应该进行投票。我们在投什么票？
Do you even know what PDA means? I'm with you. It's so funny. What you can't see, which you'll, you'll see when I put in stories, is Jim, when, when they ask, Jim stands up and Pam goes, what are you doing? And Jim starts rolling up his sleeves and he goes, sleeves, sleeves. So then Pam starts rolling up her sleeves and then he makes this big speech and then Pam is like, yes.
你们甚至知道PDA是什么意思吗？我和你们一样。太好笑了。你们看不到的，但等我发到动态里你们就能看到了，是吉姆，当他们问的时候，吉姆站起来，帕姆说，你在干什么？然后吉姆开始卷起袖子，他说，袖子，袖子。于是帕姆开始卷起袖子，然后他发表了一场宏大的演讲，接着帕姆就说，好的。
And then just starts laughing. It's such a hot mess. It's so good. You know, I loved doing these comedy scenes with John. We really had good comedic chemistry together. We had that jam brain, you know, we shared that brain. And so we really were like those people who can finish someone's sentence. I always like knew where he was going.
然后就开始大笑。这真是一团糟。太棒了。你知道的，我很喜欢和约翰一起拍这些喜剧场景。我们俩真的很有喜剧默契。我们有那种吉姆大脑，你知道的，我们共享那个大脑。所以我们真的就像那种能接住对方话的人。我总是知道他要去哪里。
I could see it. It was so fun. I can't wait for you to see the scene because he turns to you and says, sleeves, sleeves. It's just so ridiculous. Aaron and Andy's next stop on their treasure hunt is getting a sparkling cider at Hank's. I am anticipating a lip flap. Hank says, look for a heart or some sh** in the break room. Yes.
我能看出来。太有趣了。我迫不及待想让你们看这个场景，因为他转向你说，袖子，袖子。简直太荒谬了。艾琳和安迪寻宝的下一站是在汉克那里买气泡酒。我期待着嘴唇动作。汉克说，在休息室里找个心形或者什么狗屁东西。是的。
We got two notes from standards and practices in this scene. So first up, when Hank gives Aaron the bottle of sparkling cider, we had to reach out to the cider manufacturer, Martin Ellis, to get clearance, which we did, but it also generated a note from standards and practices. The note was this, this is fine, but please avoid exposure of the logo and branding on the bottle. The brand itself doesn't seem important to the storyline or joke. So sales would prefer that significant exposure be avoided.
在这个场景中，我们收到了标准与实践部门的两条意见。首先，当汉克把一瓶气泡酒给艾琳时，我们不得不联系气泡酒制造商马丁·埃利斯以获得授权，我们确实联系了，但这也引发了标准与实践部门的一条意见。意见是这样的：这很好，但请避免暴露瓶身上的标志和品牌。品牌本身对故事情节或笑话似乎并不重要。所以销售部门更希望避免明显的暴露。
Please for the love of God, no significant exposure. They don't want significant exposure of any kind. No, I know. Of people. Of labels. It doesn't matter. I hate to say, I disagree. I think seeing the Martin Ellis label makes it clear that it's sparkling cider and not
看在上帝的份上，求求你们，别有明显的暴露。他们不希望有任何形式的明显的暴露。不，我知道。关于人的。关于标签的。这不重要。我不得不说，我不同意。我认为看到马丁·埃利斯标签可以清楚地表明那是气泡酒，而不是
alcohol. And that is important to the storyline. I agree and had standards and practices read the shooting draft. They would know of this deleted scene where Aaron shares about going wine tasting, even though she doesn't like wine. It's a real awkward experience for her. So this non-alcoholic drink was intentional to the script. I have the deleted scene.
酒精。这对故事情节很重要。我同意，如果标准与实践部门读过拍摄剧本，他们就会知道有一个被删减的场景，其中艾琳分享了去品酒的经历，尽管她不喜欢酒。对她来说这是一次真正的尴尬经历。所以这种不含酒精的饮料在剧本中是有意安排的。我有被删减的场景。
Let's hear it. Oh my gosh. Okay. You're going to love this story. So last Saturday Gabe took me wine tasting. You hate wine. I know, but I'm trying to learn to like it. So anyway, so the wine guy opens a new bottle and he hands me the cork and I don't know
让我们听听。哦天哪。好吧。你们会喜欢这个故事的。所以上周六加布带我去品酒。你讨厌酒。我知道，但我正努力学着去喜欢它。所以无论如何，品酒师打开了一瓶新酒，他把木塞递给我，我不知道
what to do. Well, yeah, I mean, well, what did you do? Well, I didn't know what to do. So I put it in my mouth. What? I know. I thought you were supposed to taste it. Oh my gosh.
该怎么办。好吧，我是说，你做了什么？嗯，我不知道该怎么办。所以我把它放进嘴里。什么？我知道。我以为你应该尝尝它。哦天哪。
That sounds like I am listening to Ed and Ellie talking. I have to be honest, like not that Ellie would do that, but that sounded so natural. Well they improvised quite a bit in that scene. So some of it scripted and some of it's not, but standards and practices. You guys would have seen the dailies, right? The second moment from the scene that standards and practices had to comment on was Hank's line, Angela, you're correct. He says, and I'm supposed to tell you to enjoy a mid-hunt break and look for heart stickers
听起来我好像在听埃德和埃莉说话。老实说，倒不是说埃莉会做出那种事，但听起来太自然了。好吧，他们在那个场景里即兴发挥了很多。所以有些是剧本里的，有些不是，但标准与实践部门。你们一定看过样片，对吧？该场景中标准与实践部门必须发表评论的第二个时刻是汉克的台词，安吉拉，你说得对。他说，我应该告诉你们在寻宝中途休息一下，并在结束后在休息室里寻找心形贴纸
or some in the break room when you're through. And it was all supposed to rhyme, but I forgot how it goes. You get it. Here's what they said, please bleep Hank's remark completely with no beginning or end consonant sounds and blur the visible lip flap or stage him off camera. It's a busy day for standards and practices that day. I know that scene really, a lot of emails. You know, we were talking with Greg in the lobby after his interview and we were talking
或者某些东西。而且本来应该全部押韵的，但我忘了是怎么说的。你们懂的。以下是他们的原话：请彻底消音汉克的言论，不要留下任何开头或结尾的辅音，并模糊可见的嘴唇动作或将他安排在镜头外。对标准与实践部门来说，那天是个忙碌的日子。我知道那个场景真的有很多电子邮件。你知道的，我们在他采访完后在门厅跟格雷格聊天，我们谈到了
about our delight over standards and practices and he said that doesn't even happen anymore. Yeah. It's like a department that's gone. We were so sad to hear it. I mean, he said on streaming for sure it's gone. I don't know about network. Yeah. He said, there's no blurring of the lip flap on Netflix.
我们对标准与实践部门的喜爱，他说现在甚至都不会发生这种事了。是的。这就像是一个已经消失的部门。听到这个消息我们很难过。我是说，他说在流媒体上这绝对已经消失了。电视网我就不知道了。是的。他说，在Netflix上不会对嘴唇动作进行模糊处理。
No. There's no snarky email. Well we need to revisit the Michael and Holly storyline for a second because Michael's really bummed. Something Gabe said has stuck with him and it's that Holly is eventually going to go back to Nashua. Yeah. And what does that mean for their relationship?
没有。也没有尖酸刻薄的电子邮件。好吧，我们需要暂时重新审视迈克尔和霍莉的故事情节，因为迈克尔真的很沮丧。加布说的话一直盘旋在他脑海里，那就是霍莉最终还是要回纳舒厄。是的。这对外他们的关系意味着什么？
Dwight's trying to cheer him up. He's rocking him? Kind of rocking him in his chair? Yes. And then Kevin is going to make silly faces. Yeah. He had a fan question from Chad E in Canada at 17 minutes and 59 seconds. Michael wants to see more monkey go back to monkey.
德怀特正试图让他振作起来。他在摇晃他？有点像在椅子上摇晃他？是的。然后凯文要做鬼脸。是的。他在加拿大查德·E那里收到一个粉丝提问，在17分59秒时。迈克尔想看更多猴子，回到猴子状态。
This seemed improvised. Was it scripted? Well I looked in the script. The scripted scene ended after Michael says, I love it. So it was scripted that Kevin is going to make funny faces and then he acts like a monkey and then Michael said, I love it. And that was the end. The whole rest of the scene was improvised.
这看起来是即兴发挥。是剧本里的吗？嗯，我查了剧本。剧本场景在迈克尔说“我喜欢”之后就结束了。所以剧本里写的是凯文要做鬼脸，然后他表现得像只猴子，接着迈克尔说“我喜欢”。这就是结尾。剩下的整个场景都是即兴发挥的。
Yes. Greg and Robert shared on the commentary that it was a scene that was added late and at first they wrote that Jim was the one making the crazy faces but then they realized that Jim actually is with Pam looking for a place to hook up so he couldn't physically be in both places at once so they made it Kevin. I loved it. Me too. Erin is going to get her final treasure.
是的。格雷格和罗伯特在评论音轨中分享说，这是一个很晚才加入的场景，起初他们写的是吉姆在做疯狂的表情，但后来他们意识到吉姆实际上正和帕姆在一起找地方亲热，所以他不可能同时身处两个地方，于是他们把它改成了凯文。我很喜欢。我也是。艾琳要去拿她最后的宝藏。
B9. It's a cookie. And there's a poem on the back of the cookie that says she's going to get her Valentine's kiss. And then Gabe does the weirdest, blow you a kiss I've ever seen in my whole life. He didn't want to walk in and kiss her? The end of this treasure hunt, this whole treasure hunt, imagine you're Erin. You've spent all day on all these things.
B9。是一个饼干。饼干背面有一首诗，说她会得到她的情人节之吻。然后加布做出了我这辈子见过最诡异的飞吻动作。他不想走进去亲吻她吗？这场寻宝的结尾，整场寻宝，想象一下你是艾琳。你一整天都花在所有这些事情上。
I mean she's delighted because she spent it with Andy. But then at the end, could you imagine if the end of it was just Josh blowing you a kiss through a window pane, but like blowing me a kiss that he kissed into his fist and then he kind of bleh, he kind of like makes it go, yeah, what? I know. Well, Gabe has made a science out of Valentine's Day. I know. Gabe, a science of what?
我的意思是她很高兴，因为她是和安迪一起度过的。但最后，你能想象如果结局只是乔希透过窗格隔空给你一个吻，但就像是把飞吻亲进拳头里然后他有点“布勒”，他有点像发出那种声音，呃，什么？我知道。好吧，加布把情人节变成了一门科学。我知道。加布，什么的一门科学？
Meanwhile, Michael's going to break up with Holly. You know what? Actually, he's going to wait till tomorrow. He shouldn't do this on Valentine's Day. No. And she's like, we're not breaking up. And this is that moment we talked about with Greg, where Holly says, you know, they don't get to decide our future.
与此同时，迈克尔要和霍莉分手。你知道吗？实际上，他要等到明天。他不该在情人节做这件事。不。而她说，我们没有分手。这就是我们和格雷格讨论过的那个时刻，霍莉说，你知道的，他们无权决定我们的未来。
We will decide our future. The most precious look of relief and happiness comes over Michael's face. It's so sweet. And they're going to go into the bullpen and they are going to announce to everyone that they are officially moving in together. So I shared on the commentary and I almost got a clip of it. And then I was like, is that weird to play myself from 10 years ago? I was like, that's probably weird, so I'll just share.
我们将决定我们的未来。迈克尔脸上露出了无比珍贵的释怀和幸福的表情。太甜了。然后他们要走进办公区，向所有人宣布他们正式同居了。所以我分享了评论音轨，我差点剪辑了其中的一个片段。然后我想，播放自己10年前的样子会很奇怪吗？我想，那可能很奇怪，所以我还是分享吧。
I said, this is the first time that Michael has a real family outside of his Dunder Mifflin family. And Greg was like, you're absolutely right. This is the beginning of Michael being able to separate from the work group because he's happy finally at home. Yeah, he has a home he wants to go home to. Yeah. You know, in the middle of this scene, Jim and Pam are going to enter from a door.
我说，这是迈克尔在邓德米夫林家族之外第一次拥有真正的家庭。格雷格说，你绝对说得对。这是迈克尔能够脱离工作群体开始，因为他在家里终于感到了幸福。是的，他有一个他想回的家。是的。你知道，在这个场景中间，吉姆和帕姆将从一扇门走进来。
The door by accounting, which has never been used before. Read what I put in all caps in my document. From the magic door by accounting, first time ever. Exclamation point. So we know what was behind that door. What was behind that door were the actual cast restrooms, the cast green room where you could sit on some couches and watch a live feed of whatever we were taping. When they brought in network executives, maybe for a visit, it happened very rarely.
会计部门旁边的门，这扇门以前从来没用过。读读我在文档里用全大写字母写的内容。从会计部门旁边的魔幻门出来，史无前例。感叹号。所以我们知道那扇门后面是什么。那扇门后面实际上是演员洗手间，演员休息室，你可以在那里坐在沙发上观看我们正在拍摄的任何内容的实时画面。当他们带电视网高管进来时，也许是来参观，这种情况非常罕见。
They could sit in that room. When we had charity winners or when we had family visiting, they could sit in that room. It was sort of for guests and cast, although the cast rarely used it. We never had the time. We were on stage. We were on stage. But it's definitely where you and I went quick like a bunny and went pee all the time. Yes.
他们可以坐在那个房间里。当我们有慈善中奖者或者有家人来访时，他们可以坐在那个房间。这里有点像是为客人和演员准备的，虽然演员很少用。我们从来没有时间。我们在台上。我们在台上。但这绝对是你和我经常飞快地跑去上厕所的地方。是的。
But we never have seen, even still, we will see in season nine, what the world of Dunder Mifflin says is behind that door. So Jim and Pam enter, we were originally supposed to enter through the front door. That is how it was scripted, that we sneak back into the office. And then later, when Jim and Pam have their talking head and we say we were taking a walk, and it kind of made sense. But on the day, we got in a big discussion with Greg where we were like, where were we?
但我们从来没见过，甚至直到现在，我们将在第九季中看到，邓德米夫林的世界里说那个门后面是什么。所以吉姆和帕姆进去了，我们原本应该从正门进入。剧本里就是这么写的，我们溜回办公室。后来，当吉姆和帕姆做访谈时，我们说我们在散步，这倒也说得通。但在拍摄当天，我们和格雷格进行了激烈的讨论，我们在想，我们是从哪里来的？
If we were coming in from the front door. The whole point is to hook up in the office somewhere. Yes. And the warehouse would have counted, but we've already explained that Jim and Pam couldn't find a warehouse spot. So we're like, where are they coming from? He didn't want us to enter through the kitchen and have to plow through Michael and Holly. Too much walking.
如果我们是从正门进来的。关键是要在办公室的某个地方约会。是的。仓库本来也可以算，但我们已经解释过吉姆和帕姆找不到仓库里的位置。所以我们在想，他们是从哪儿来的？他不想让我们从厨房进来，还得费劲穿过迈克尔和霍莉。走的路太多了。
And also not very sneaky. So we picked that door first time. Magic door. And that is where baby Philip was made behind that door. Well this episode ends with what feels like to me like a when Harry met Sally montage of people talking about romance or Valentine's. Sure. It starts with Dwight.
而且也不怎么鬼祟。所以我们第一次就选了那扇门。神奇的门。婴儿菲利普就是在那个门后被造出来的。好吧，这一集结束时的感觉对我来说就像是《当哈利遇到莎莉》那样，有一段关于浪漫或情人节的蒙太奇。当然。从德怀特开始。
He's going to say his perfect Valentine's Day is filling calls from three different cell phones from desperate people trying to purchase one of the 50 dinner reservations he made six months ahead of time. This is very princess unicorn. Yep. Ryan is going to say anyone can be Prince Charming once a year. What impresses him as a guy that can do it? No days a year.
他说他完美的的情人节是从三个不同的手机上接听电话，电话那头是绝望的人，他们想买下他在六个月前提早预订的50个晚餐预约中的一个。这非常像独角兽公主。没错。瑞安会说，任何人一年中都可以做一次白马王子。让他印象深刻的是一个一年365天都能做到的人。
Kelly says flowers, diamonds, three course meal, private serenade from a violinist. Kevin says pizza soda the moon. Someone to share it with. Michael and Holly say one of their plans tonight. Then Holly makes that noise like the bed squeaky noise. There were even more as everyone else chimed in from the bullpen and I thought you guys should hear them. The senator is pampering me tonight.
凯利说鲜花、钻石、三道菜的套餐、小提琴家的私人小夜曲。凯文说披萨、苏打水、月亮。一个可以分享这一切的人。迈克尔和霍莉说他们今晚的计划之一。然后霍莉发出了那种类似床咯吱咯吱响的声音。当其他人从开放式办公区加入进来时，甚至还有更多，我觉得你们应该听听。参议员今晚在纵容我。
At six o'clock we're having dinner at Mason La Orange followed by homemade marzipan. And then at eight thirty he has to meet his aide Thomas to talk about work. I guess a little BBC America, a little Vietnamese food, a little Pinot, a little Google Maps street view of Paris, c'est magnifique. I'm weighing my options. Probably going to bike down to the wharf, see what's cooking down there. I will not buy a flower in a restaurant from a beggar. If you try to sell me a flower while I'm eating my chicken parm, you better cover your balls.
六点钟我们在橘子树餐厅吃晚餐，接着是自制杏仁膏。然后八点半他必须去见他的助手托马斯谈工作。我想，来一点BBC美国台，来一点越南菜，来一点黑皮诺，来一点谷歌地图的巴黎街景，真是太美妙了。我正在权衡我的选择。可能会骑自行车去码头，看看那里在做什么。我绝不会在餐馆里从乞丐手里买花。如果你在我吃帕尔马鸡排时试图向最好卖花，你最好护好你的蛋蛋。
Dweck! Well, well, I loved those. That's everybody. And of course, Jim and Pam have that very cute talking head together. And they're like, what? No. And then Pam has a little look to camera like, we did it. So Angela, before we wrap out this episode, I did have a really fun fan love story from
德韦克！好吧，我很喜欢这些。这就是所有人。当然，吉姆和帕姆有一个非常可爱的共同访谈。他们就像是，什么？没有。然后帕姆朝镜头看了一眼，仿佛在说，我们做到了。所以安吉拉，在我们结束这一集之前，我真的有一个非常有趣的粉丝爱情故事来自
Logan D and Bellevue, Nebraska. I thought what a fun way to end this Valentine's Day episode. I can't wait. Logan said, I love this episode and it holds a special place in my heart. My partner, my soup snake, Diane and I met on Tinder mostly because of my profile pic. What was the profile pic? It was me in a Dunder Mifflin shirt, Dunder Mifflin's wet pants in front of a Dunder Mifflin sign at the office experience when it was in Chicago.
内布拉斯加州贝尔维尤的洛根·D。我觉得这是结束这个情人节特辑的一个有趣方式。我等不及了。洛根说，我喜欢这一集，它在我心中占据着特殊的位置。我的伴侣，我的心灵伴侣，黛安和我是在Tinder上认识的，主要是因为我的个人资料照片。个人资料照片是什么？是我穿着邓德米夫林衬衫，在办公室体验活动芝加哥站的邓德米夫林标志前穿着邓德米夫林的湿裤子。
Her profile said, I'm not superstitious, but I am a little stitious. And that she was, quote, looking for a Dwight to her Angela. Aw. Well, we started talking because of that huge office connection and it turns out we are way more of a Holly Michael dynamic through and through. After a couple weeks of dating, we got even more office gear and took a road trip to the office experience in Chicago. I know.
她的个人资料上写着，我并不迷信，但我有点迷信。而且她说她，引述一下，在寻找一个属于她的安吉拉的德怀特。噢。好吧，我们因为那个巨大的办公室联系而开始聊天，事实证明，我们自始至终更像是霍莉和迈克尔的动态。约会几周后，我们买到了更多的办公室周边，并自驾去了芝加哥的办公室体验。我知道。
We had a blast. When we got back home, the L word dropped. We fittingly told each other that we loved loved each other and the rest is history. Our common love of the show is what brought us together and continues to bring us closer and closer over time. Aw. Logan and Diane, congratulations on finding love through the office. I love those stories.
我们玩得很开心。当我们回到家时，那个L开头的词说出口了。我们很合时宜地告诉对方我们爱彼此，剩下的就是历史了。我们对这部剧共同的热爱将我们聚在一起，并且随着时间的推移，让我们越来越亲密。噢。洛根和黛安，祝贺你们通过办公室找到了爱。我很喜欢这些故事。
Me too. You guys, we hope you have the best week. That was it for PDA and for you guys in the UK public display of affection. Thank you so much, Greg Daniels for coming in studio and joining us today. Thank you to Randy Cordray for all your fun tidbits. And thank you guys for listening and rewatching with us. Next week, we'll be answering our mail bag. See you then.
我也是。大家，我们希望你们度过最好的一周。这就是PDA的内容，对于英国的你们来说是公开秀恩爱。非常感谢格雷格·丹尼尔斯来到录音室加入我们今天的节目。感谢兰迪·科德雷分享所有有趣的趣闻。谢谢大家收听并与我们重温。下周，我们将回答我们的邮件信箱。到时见。
See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoke. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·巴比科克。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。有关《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需免费试用一个月 Stitcher Premium，请使用代码 OFFICE。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。